and you hear us we need to make sure you
can hear us can you hear me from here if
we're if if we're live we need
confirmation you can hear him hear me
from back here and you hear us
hello can you see me we are looking at
two different computer screens this is a
different comments and can't tell if you
can hear us we got somebody infected in
the chat Marcus Dowell are you okay you
okay your career recovering it's all
kinds of [ __ ] okay people can hear
us they can hear us
Marcus Dale I'm sorry to hear that cos
right make sure to just ask questions
guys I figured out how to put the
graphic on screen for today's theme it's
right here movies geared man you did not
like until rewatch or movies you did
like and then Yuri watch that [ __ ] and
you were like nah I don't like it
I got a few let's see who's in the chat
right now okay we got some people
Phillip blaze Jules
Sami before that's so nice of you del
you seen Jacob tube a couple crazy uh
who and these are a friend who was um
Carter who who's our friend here who
said there's a quarantine right now
because they actually have the the thing
oh yeah scroll up on the YouTube one
where's Marcus Dowell there you Marcus
tile I hope you feel better buddy
yeah tell us what you like tell us what
you like and we'll see what we can
hopefully we put a smile on your face
tonight that's the goal for today
all right guys start what I I appreciate
everything that you guys just start
naming the movies in the chat we'll read
them off we'll read them off row right
Raj general we will but just start
naming off the movies in there you guys
helped drive this stream and then John
and I take way too long sometimes on
topics that's how it goes also Mimi M
check that patreon in a half hour
all right so we got so okay hey we
already got it we got one here dude
geared towards you went well thank you
gear Triggs I you guys have no idea
what's in store I've been talking with
him I have to reply to you we've been
talked
a lot on Instagram lately he is he just
followed him on Instagram you'll see
what he has he's winning against Amber
Heard he makes these amazing ass custom
shoes if you will the second he looked
like a few of his I don't want to spoil
it for you guys and I've asked him I
said here's what I would like and I
don't want to spoil it for anyone what I
asked for
and I don't want him to send me a photo
of it I'm just waiting for him to send
it to me and I'm gonna unbox it on
camera so thank you dude you don't need
a super chair throwing down a lot for us
right now so yeah what else do we got in
the chat here have you hate John if you
listen you strokes album I have not your
strokes fan I like the strokes you're a
huge stroke biggest strokes man you'll
ever meet so many times I've seen you
guys are into the strokes you will want
to talk to Joe I haven't only seen
Julianne perform solo yeah I mean I've
heard three new songs off the new record
so far the first you know very cynthy
one yeah the number of they're called I
like the three songs I heard though so
I'm I'm very curious to hear the album
because their past few have been a
little up and down
I like tangles person spirit okay I need
to clarify something I appreciate
everyone who has chimed in on the
comments I really do what out will need
so far for the movies is specificity
that'll be really important because I'm
seeing some people saying Godzilla 2014
transformers parasite I we need to know
is there's gotta be a short version to
say it so that way not the type a whole
bunch because I know typing is annoying
yeah which is these two is it you did
not like it
until rewatch or did like until rewatch
so you can just say did like or did not
and that'll be the way of knowing what
it is and then we'll see if we agree or
disagree and to give you guys an example
of what I mean um I I'm gonna give you a
hint I didn't know about this whole Cova
thing cuz I was on an island meditating
Jer letter did not like him then I
rewatched your letter
suicide I actually like Suicide Squad
the first time I watched it I was like
what's the big deal and then I rewatched
it and I was like oh my god this is a
this is not a good movie what's the hell
did I like it for and then we watch the
extended cutting it was even worse yeah
so so John what's one movie for you
um one movie that I didn't love too much
on first viewing that I came back around
in a big way on the second time was the
original Fright Night that movie a lot
of people love mmm I saw it for the
first time I was like okay sure
and I saw it the second time I was like
this is so fun I get it now yeah so yeah
Fright Night go watch it call good call
so I'm gonna go through the car okay
oh hey Rock right I reckon I remember
your your thumbnail your icon great
image hey guys thanks for liking my icon
last name I'm liking it again still
mother double like my assistant opinion
my pick would be I wonder how long I can
maintain this energy for before I really
just have a hard crash right here I'll
get real chill and take over when you do
my pick would be Godzilla 2014 love it
that's the first reaction I watched you
guys six years ago oh wait a minute well
thank you so much - we gotta bring
salamander sally back on him even if she
has it was a stringer in here whether
you say you didn't like it the first you
did like it the first time and then you
liked it the second time this is why we
need clarity I think this falls on me
for not being clear upfront about the
clarity of the situation I think there's
record it but if you love it now that's
cool I I was a little bit lukewarm on it
the first time and it was actually that
was a rare case of a movie that I
thought about and then I ended up really
liking it was kind of like Pirates of
the Caribbean Dead Man's Chest really
did not like it the first time I watched
it and then one night I was know a day I
don't want to lie to you guys who was
during the day was the time and during
the day I was taking a walk and I was
like thinking about some scenes and I
was like starting to understand what the
movie was really all about and then I
just found myself going I think I love
this movie
and the Godzilla kind of had a similar
effect but a lot quicker like the day of
that kind of thing
hey Jenna Randolph Jenna Raj is in here
somewhere they yell snaps and Raj's in
here ooh okay see we got someone coming
in the chat I liked BBS until where you
watch the hype war off
BAM that's some strong hype I've seen
BBS twice I liked it a little bit more
the second time I watched it because I
saw it on IMAX and any time they shoot a
movie with IMAX cameras I'm a bit of a
sucker for it I'm being totally honest
and yeah BVS was no did you watch it
twice we just watched the one time and
then we came back and did that weird ass
never seen her BBS are weirdest shot
reviews that way we're like let's really
experiment and have Tony hand-held this
whole thing yeah like it's some kind of
weird occupy on a random chat weird
experiment we did there it's fun though
I mean yeah I don't know maybe we should
take more review when movies exist again
maybe we should take more reviews up
right that's a fair note that's a fair
no boo oh yeah we did notice you Sammy
Buford don't get don't don't get that
get used to it so we got a lord
crocodile in here who's saying that he
agrees or she agrees with us I don't
know
Laura Martinez back in the chat got some
goofy movie love called Tara Ericsson
and she said hi Oh apparently action arm
is doing a live stream right now as well
can we get them can we patch them in man
I just I iced guys I did not hit my
notification bell for them because I
really didn't want to oh I got to tell
you guys until then you said that Andrew
guy does not like little people I know
it's a weird thing but if you guys want
to go over to that stream at some point
and just tell them Greg told me some
facts about you Andrew a guy he says you
don't like little people he doesn't even
use that terminology I'm just saying
it's it's it's nasty nasty man yeah I
wish Trump would say that reporters
nasty man nasty man just doesn't this
doesn't come off the tongue as well
nasty man
the amount of times he calls people
woman I want him to call men men just be
real blunt about it it seems like a lot
of people are agreeing with the whole
suicide squad one here the house that
okay yeah for the glasses submit movies
and then tell us the opposite for king
of the monsters is not love king of the
monsters record Dillo did and I thank
you guys so much for being here the live
streams are the most fun of the week
we've been having on YouTube so far so
thank you guys and keep keep submitting
what's the title on this video right
here geared towards ink is not taking my
advice I do not like knives out until I
rewatched it I could you know I could
actually see that thank you by the way
buddy I don't think you ever told me
your real name by the way we're talking
so much and I like what's this guy's
[ __ ] really what does he look like it
looks like that handsome it opened up as
saying what name does he look like he
looks like a tyrona Kisan I'm Dante
yeah because knives out is a movie that
I've seen a lot of people kind of get
annoyed by at first weirdly I've seen
people get upset by the fact of how it's
not a typical who's done it because they
tell you pretty much upfront what
happened is that I ran shots and loves
subvert Tim expectations and so some
people wanted something a little bit
more traditional but I think for me I
settled in I just appreciate it I was
like clever kind of like how I felt with
the last Jedi
funny enough I rewatched the last Jedi
on this on the leading up to rises
Skywalker and I did not like it as much
I was a major defender of that movie and
then when I rewatched I was like I don't
think I like this movie actually there's
a lot of Indian I didn't like I know
it's not crazy John has crazy John is it
crazy I didn't lie for the most divisive
movies myself believe oh we got Lynnae
in the charlie committee lane you can
submit your own movies too man Oh
somebody just called out punish reward
when I think of another movie I disliked
in the way
- like them and disliked I'll let you
know someone said pulp fiction nope -
hell yes ha that's a big old turn around
with that's a fair that's a fair
assessment oh yeah we we always fall
behind on these I have to specifically
shout out Josh Wren hey John how do we
go you go find it again in the nucleus
to it - Oh Josh burns right here
I found Josh rent just him he said I
hated Baywatch now it's a guilty
pleasure film and I could I could meet
you there on gay watch we did guilty
pleasures last week by the way Thank You
Josh Ren Thank You Ren is a sexy name by
the way but I would never say that about
a woman I know named Ren
because that would get me cancelled just
say it about the corridor crew read that
Ren is they say if I say it about a guy
guys won't take it so first of all
unless he's a gay guy good thing gay
guys were like oh how offensive I'm
kidding gay guys love it I speak for all
gay men they elected me during the
primaries it was on your belly got a
better sense of humor didn't like John
wick 3 until someone Moosa Green Lantern
I watched it when I was really young and
thought it was great but after hearing
that everyone hated I had to rewatch its
spoiler alert not good that's a rare
thing for someone to say that for Green
Lantern John you can't think of one
other movie I can think of a billion
movies hated that you didn't like until
rewatch or then you you liked it until
you rewatch it and was like screw this
movie I'm trying to think it's been a
long times ever you watched we're
getting Ocean's Twelve in here and
oceans - you had all day to think about
it I know I've been working on it so
what god damn okay I got another one for
you Napoleon Dynamite thought it was
stupidest [ __ ] the first time I watched
it things like we watched it loved it I
keep sitting here remembering stories
like that that you've told me I'm
sitting here going oh yeah the Napoleon
Dynamite hot rod all these movies I
remember talking with you about or you
were like I know you like this but I
hated it the first time I'm trying to
dig deep here right now fine fine fine
you know I didn't care for either was a
child's play and then when weary watched
it before the remake I thought that was
an incredibly effective movies so I
think it aged well with me yeah it's not
great but very good answer John terrific
I just thought you know I thought I
really thought this would be your jam
today I'm always trying to work around
you for these topics to make people
happy and this is this is failing that
this is failing this is the first time
I've been under the hot like the hot
lights usually it's like okay I
discussed my favorite movie Ocean's
Twelve I you know what I remember about
Ocean's Twelve John's dad did not with
Julia Roberts thing he was not about I
like that movie more than ocean's 13
that's a hot take I think it's better
than ocean's 13 I actually fell asleep
during ocean's 13 both times I've
watched it sorry that's not a fair
assessment because I should stay awake
for I get a little bored when I watch
that movie that's a fair point
I was just watching a great Patrick H
Williams video about heist movies and he
singled out the oceans films and part of
it oh well thank you for clearing that
up rack Adil oh yeah go that's one topic
now did it godzilla first time and then
loved it are you talking about the 2014
godzilla yes because i would say this in
Reverse for the role in emmerich
godzilla because the cool thing to do is
not like that film oh there you go look
at that when in reality correct quite
enjoys the roland emmerich movie a lot
and it's kind of a childhood favorite of
it it's really really [ __ ]
entertaining I'm just saying Oh stupid
as [ __ ] but super entertaining I mean
this is one as a soft spot in my heart
but I used to adore the film version of
lost in space lost in space has a great
film
I've watched that music video all the
time I mean mental plays in my heart but
it is not a terrific movie
we got master B reactor here saying I
did not like a quiet place the first
time them re-- watched and loved it Oh
God to see you master being Britney Lang
even on a Friday she's here we normally
do this on Saturday but we thought to
mix it up this week and she's thank you
so much Britney how is it going over
there in Canada how's that universal
health care doing mmm Bernie's
constantly talking about how you are
just right around the corner and you
guys get universal health care and we
don't we're behind Bernie Sanders wants
us to become Canadian that's what I'm
trying to tell you so we love you
Britney Lange hey guys hope you're
staying healthy and staying safe but the
show I've been watching is How I Met
Your Mother and I've been watching to
all the boys I love and part two oh I've
seen all of How I Met Your Mother
I've seen two both of two all the boys I
love and part two wasn't that bad
actually I way prefer Part one and Part
two really a shot kind of like the
haunting of Hill House not not editing
or paste but the cinematography looks a
lot like the house and I was pretty
distracted by that the whole time like
for a romantic comedy this is striking
that gorgeous that I'm watching I'm glad
you're staying safe Brittany and I love
the new profile pic keep it up change it
every week for us can you do it just for
Greg do it we do it just for Greg Greg
II would get me cancelled yes you've got
to be careful not to endear gotta be
Nili affectionate we got someone in here
saying spider-man which spider-man are
you referring to though buddy they're
Spider Men now
ooh I box at night 23 and he earns five
dollars and nights a box and now he's
given us that super chat thank you buddy
thank you very much
you must be a top contender there on the
streets own saucer of Utah underground
crazy boxing in Utah in case you guys
didn't know
oh yeah under the Salt Lake
didn't like Joker that much the first
time I think that's because I was
expecting a lot of action boom boom
fight yeah yeah I wish that was a real
review I read on rotten tomatoes without
exclamation marks
boom boom fight didn't like Joker that
much the first time I think it's because
I was expecting a lot of action boom
boom fight but there was a lack of boom
boom in the movie oh well I got what's
up sorry another one came no John away
so other live streams go is once we get
it going then they start coming to me
well they've been coming to me since the
time I announced it at 1:30 I gotta tell
you I'm kind of in Reverse with you on
this right now
I rewatched Joker last week cuz we did a
trailers revisit and I'm gonna get a lot
of but it's true I we did trailers
revisited we did a live stream and when
I came back home because I wanted to
grab a Beyond taco from Del Taco that I
I was I was really in the mood to watch
Joker
because I think this is on the drive
beyond talking about Joker so much on
the on the drive through I was listening
to a Cora Quarantine video the
quarantined ice Joaquin Phoenix did this
wonderful podcast with his two sisters
and it really dives deep into the
performance and I was like I really
belong just watch this movie now and I
love Joker when we saw in the theaters I
loved it and then the second time and re
watching it like the first half hour I
was like oh my god yes the [ __ ] tone
and Alice fear and mood in the
performance so good yeah and then in the
middle chunk of that movie and by the
way guys I know there's so many super
chaste really do appreciate it we will
get to them but we have a habit or
sometimes take you too much of time on
aging with you and then the second time
i rewatch every watched it last week I
really hit me I'm not a big fan of like
the middle chunk or that movie there's
very writ large that yeah the way the
scripting for that film was done I'm I
so much because what I ended up doing
rewatching is the big debate with Joker
is is this hole in this guy's head so I
just wanted to look out for that for
most of
movie and then I found myself excusing
poorly written dialogue scenes that were
just the logical and moments that were
just that's just not how this would go
down this is not real wit - if it's all
in his head then I guess that's fine but
I really loved the first half-hour and I
really loved the last half-hour and
throughout walking Phoenix's performance
is great but upon rewatch I actually
liked it less which was a sad thing for
me to experience I feel yeah I mean my
main as long as we're hot take and I
mean there's a lot to appreciate about
Joker and my main beef with it is that I
think if you remove the Batman mystique
and have the same movie it would not
have grabbed everybody the way right
that's very true I just don't think at
all it would without a different script
oh my god della you're okay so Delia
scene has brought something up in the
chat that I want to throw your way
because I
Della's talking about Ghostbusters 2016
thinking it was okay and then watching a
review from red letter media changed
Ella's mind so I'm gonna ask you guys
has there ever been a movie that you
actually liked or didn't like and then
you watch the review different opinion
than yours but you were actually
persuaded and had your eyes open to the
point where you changed your opinion for
that review put that in the comments and
then yeah specified in and that in the
briefest way you can please
yeah keep these succinct so we can quote
as many of you as possible
matte beer up hey Matt beer how's it
going I love a good McChicken my beer
don't even well Matt beer I can't have
make chickens because I am now
pescetarian and I also want to also say
on pescetarian every time would that
snobbish tone as if I'm better than
everyone who's not a pescetarian oh hold
on let me get you a cookie you you thank
you are you a pescetarian oh yeah good
choices for recently I gave up meat oh
wow because it took a while I'm just
better than anyone who eats meat now
so I can't have your tasty McChicken but
we'll take the super Holi to make right
we got a comment in here of Assam thank
you map here we got a comment here to
someone saying I don't think this ever
happened at me whenever hater movie I've
never watched it a second time that's
how I read your comment there's got to
be there's got to be another one
Oh Mike Oh Lynnae Jones thank you so
much your how'd you like WWE last week
by the way people have seen me a lot
more positive about that sport as of
late but it's not but you know it's a
real sport movie trivia Schmo down not
that wrestling [ __ ] no Schmo down
getting lucky on some question real
that's a real it's not a fan of WWE
I hope someone take that snippet send a
harloff as if I'm talking match in have
you seen Inside Man yeah I liked Inside
Man a lot only Spike Lee film that John
has seen and that's because Clive Owen
and Jodie Foster are that's right fairy
that's true and and that other guy from
those other movies very to remember his
name
yeah what is it Don Sal Ejiofor yeah
yeah Jomon they're both inside man did
not like it the first time so much going
to think about but liked it the second
time after paying attention to it please
get a lot better when you pay you know
Linnea when you pay attention to the
movies oftentimes they are more enjoy
there's so much better should I mention
Lynnae I'm a pescetarian what so I can't
whoa I can't enjoy some of that Texas
meat will you fire but maybe you can
enjoy some of John's yeah Texas meat oh
oh
Texas sighs joke canceled John oh yeah
oh can you imagine if the culture work
that way
I'm gonna be like ten gently' cancelled
bad we got a generous thank you Lynnae
so much you're so freakin sweet schnitz
and I hope you're staying safe out then
I hope your grandparents are okay my
husband I made the mistake of watching
neverending story which we love those
kids
talk about a shattering a childhood
memory really that is no that is a
slingshot of an effect yeah let me talk
to you guys about Jenna's question which
childhood movie was ruined for you upon
rewatch as an adult and if you're a kid
super G what do you think will be ruined
for you when you're older use your best
judgment and what do you like now that's
actually good aw don't cry Sammy please
don't cry I didn't like inception at
first Josh Williams says because I
didn't understand it but now I love it
that's perfect that's good understanding
is very helpful I actually like
inception less the second time I watched
it that was another tough times for you
I was [ __ ] in love with inception and
then when I rewatched it and by the way
I'm a pescetarian oh that's what it do
oh damn
do you have the virus you're like what
are you doing here more accenture last
time I talked to Dan he was like Alison
I repeat super strict right now we're
not having people over we're saying
quarantine very serious I was like yo
dude I respect that I've had people's
recently say Dan cyber needs to come on
this is gonna become a Dan interview a
damn purview what is a movie you're not
gonna take any more super shots it's all
Dan questions no that was a [ __ ] law
if you super test and was a boy down the
strip if you super check
hey hey Dan have you played god of war
recently don't we're gonna get to
everyone's super chat to keep going
through the questions in a second oh
yeah the one from like last year or so
well I have recently started playing
it's a fantastic game I don't want to do
anything productive I have to go at it
like fortunately olivia has beat the
game three times already
oh my so I have like whenever I'm stuck
I'm like time for this Olivia players
free I don't look it up on YouTube makes
the world a difference you join us for
the stream were your own channel or for
game theory you would never say that
about game theory I want you guys to
know that right now go subscribe the
game theory in that cypher channel by
the way playlists running yeah all those
ads I'm glad you could stop by Dan Ohio
this year really you could just be
saying that has the wipes forgotten
better since Dan showed up or is it
worse now leave your thoughts down below
yeah I could just see all those numbers
plummeting these go to 11
well Dan thank you for stopping by Dan
thank glad to see you're doing healthy
and don't worry our home is a lot
cleaner than yours I'm just saying your
home is a piece of [ __ ] then we hate
your hate your home and are way more
Clem lean on your wrists which you are
kneeling on right now and send the
highest carpet carpet
go for it thank you for stopping by dad
cameo here at the mornings do all we
need now is a sound board to place silly
sounds never know what's gonna happen oh
I was talking about Inception Street
Fighter you're not to get in a fight
with somebody
Carter Lovejoy thank you so much Cargill
Oh Joe you are to bomb
I watched silver linings playbook for
the first time like three years ago and
I'm didn't like but after second viewing
I enjoyed it really I love silver
linings playbook the first time I
thought so relax but I cried I think I
cried too much cry way too easily I'm
just a weepy pescetarian I'm kind of
like looking to cry you know why because
I'm a man and I think the thing about
men is they're often afraid to cry and I
think to be a real man you got to face
your fears
so when I cry I'm being more manly than
the rest of the men you flex really hard
when you cry and by the way did I
mention I'm a pescetarian this man just
let's hear it let's give a round of
applause from a man's over here not
better than the vegetarians or the
vegans or the people who don't eat food
at all but I am better better than the
Paleo Pete and I'm better than the paleo
[ __ ] [ __ ] those paleo yeah there you
go [ __ ] all the meat-eaters you got to
get a warrant and for some of the people
in the livestream unfortunately Carl
Lovejoy I appreciate you carte blanche
maybe that's an interesting choice I
wonder what was it about your rewatch
that made you like it oh um you know
what I didn't like as much the second
time was birdman' birdman oddly and
really did not yeah something came off
like it was weird the first time I could
connect to it I think I was more dazzled
you know by more things that
once whereas the second time I knew what
the style was gonna be and so I was like
okay usually I can get down with
unlikable characters but I kinda don't
like anything right no I guess you joy I
love the first time cuz I'm a snob
that's okay so we've take it too long so
I totally skip so good now it's not a so
people super jets are not showing up
here on this I'm so sorry about that but
I'm gonna do my best to make sure I
don't lose count who was the last person
we did lovejoy silver lining but nine
own are on the super shine that's a-ok
and that's why we're going through the
chat for these specific topics right
here that's the whole point guys it's
best movie of gangsters okay so after
Carl Lovejoy should be Andrew cook right
what's up lighthouse pictures where's
Andrew cook Oh what Jimmy freckles Oh
Andrew could chime in here twice okay he
did so here's what we'll do Andrew cook
all right okay thank you by the way
Andrew cook is saying to us a question
have you seen true detective if so what
are your thoughts
I think it's Matthew McConaughey's best
performance and the second thing that he
said was right here on screen sky high
age is like fine wine you know I need to
see sky high really you haven't seen and
Michael anger Rana went to my high
school I did I said I watched sky high
because I thought was gonna be stupid
and then I loved it and I went back to
the theaters and watch it again and
loved it even more I think is an
underrated ass movie I can't believe you
haven't seen I'm sure I would love it Oh
Mike Bruce Campbell's I know
gym teacher like that was one of the
Palani no Michael I'm gonna rent it
tonight Daniel Panabaker from oh yeah
and from the horror game hall thank you
Andrew detective yes I've seen the first
season a true detective my girlfriend
Olivia made sure I watch that first
season and I agree with you man
McConaughey that that probably is my
favorite performance of him brilliant
[ __ ] show that first I haven't seen
the second or third season but the first
[ __ ] brilliant and sometime I want
off is great I remember I remember
heaven is a very specific note about
Matthew McConaughey in that show because
it cuts back and forth between two
different timelines primarily you wasn't
his first partner Woody Harrelson and
post partner with Woody Harrelson so
he's like really old a little skinny and
long hair mustache and I remember like
watching him on as old guy going how is
this guy still so [ __ ] attractive
even as like this [ __ ] old dude who
just is so cynical how is he still so
attractive about time you know flat
circle and that's why John's here that
don't just why John don't take my shirt
off thank you John for being here
anytime I got the call this morning I
need McConaughey oh we got someone in
here saying they had an e saying the
Princess Bride and now loves him that's
a that's a good movie love because if
you don't love that movie you get crap
it's one of those films so it's best you
love it that is a take for sure oh I got
one I got one
The Godfather ha did not like it the
first time I watched it I was too young
to appreciate it didn't understand it I
mean I said I liked it because it was a
smart thing to say but I didn't know I
honestly didn't like it the first time I
watched it I was really slow and boring
then I rewatched it like a few years
after well that's yeah I think I don't
know if the same degree but I know that
Goodfellas definitely appreciated as I
got older because I saw when I was
younger and I was you know some gangster
scenes some stuff that's really violent
yeah and then I grew up and I was like
oh I really get this now funny enough
Matt bier saying it right there didn't
like the Godfather III did not receive a
comment and now he loves it great minds
Terry come into
different shapes isn't that funny I'm a
curator or I forget John read off one of
the movies
oh uh tango in cash that's got a special
place in our hearts
who Thor the dark world thought it was
better than the first when I saw it in
theaters when I did a rewatch of all the
movies before infinity war I fell asleep
I'm so curious to rewatch Thor that I we
own the only time we I've seen thro the
dark world was the one time you and I
went to the theaters and reviewed it yep
I remember feeling pounds over the big
deals I thought was fine
that was fun but everyone wasn't like
that's like the lowest-ranked MCU movie
and I'm kind of scared to watch it to be
like oh my god everyone was remember
watching it and thinking it was alright
and then yeah I I don't know if it
deserves the I think it's just because
it's the bottom of the list like it
might not be a dreadfully terrible film
fair enough you know it might pale in
comparison but because it's got that
status I am very curious to see it again
alright before I miss anyone though okay
okay sorry we can't get you up here in
the super chair now but I wanted to
specifically shout out chill level TV
thank you so much for contributing here
would you want a Nintendo Cinematic
Universe as a matter of fact my friend
we did a couple years ago a video where
we are specific the whole video is
specifically pitching the end see you
that way you confuse people who think
you're saying MCU into going to watch it
and they're like what's Mario doing in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe sensi yeah
we don't ever say that in the video but
yeah I vote aye
I feel like keep it at a minute I mean
would you my god I guess I throw the
question back to you guys if there was a
Nintendo Cinematic Universe I'd be cool
with it being like a bit like kind of
like what Spielberg did with Tintin
where it's an animated movie but he
still have mocap actors in there or
those like weird [ __ ] Zemeckis films
I would I wouldn't mind them doing that
at least that we still get a sense of
live-action performance but
keep it animate and then you could cross
them over I think that would be [ __ ]
awesome
but I think they would actually limit
themselves if they wanted especially if
you're like like starfox and [ __ ] the
only one that really makes sense to do
live action is Elda yeah but the other
ones feel like you should I'm gonna
watch a Donkey Kong movie probably don't
want to be animated or the Kirby or make
I mean manga manga be a pretty sweet
live-action especially if they do the
Protomen there you go say musical I mean
that would work that would work it's so
psyched and then I'll go oh we got
another one here before so we could keep
up here so skia 1999 didn't like Ocean's
Twelve till rewatching trilogy there's a
lot of Ocean's Twelve chats today so
some people seems like they liked it you
know what I wonder if Ocean's Twelve
based off your questions Oscar to Ariana
I wonder if that falls into the fact of
maybe you liked it when you were younger
and then you got older and we're like
this is bad because I feel like a movie
like Ocean's Twelve could work with
people who like me when I saw it I saw
it over like highs high school years
Robert junior highers yes I think what
you're younger it's easier to love that
movie then when you're older it's easier
to see what's stupid about yeah yeah
that's a fun when you're young I thought
it was a blast and I I I used to fall
for that whole like look at all my
favorite famous people in one movie
together yeah it's so exciting seen all
of them together so yeah I would say
that but thank you so much for coming
see the super chat there buddy
preach okay Oh Jimmy freckles ooh
the wow you look like an intimidating
ass guy you do you got that tattoo
you're the kind of guy be extra nice to
but one and want to let on that I'm
intimidated by yeah and cuz I'm unfairly
intimidated by you by a subconscious
bias that's forming in my brain of
there's really nothing about this guy
that's intimidating matter of fact it
looks like a nice gentleman but because
he has the cross the son
is the Hat sleeveless shirt oh yeah and
a tattoo there has buns
I'm medially going to assume these
probably a dangerous fellow which is
wrong of me you're profiling Jimmy but
thank you Jimmy for the super chat it's
what I'm trying to get at I'm sorry
Jimmy Jimmy I'm I really apologize I I'm
happy to hang with you
the big lebowski probably because there
wasn't buzz the first time love you
[ __ ]
um no endearment he's saying like you
know how people say these days like oh
that thing [ __ ] if it's like super
awesome I think that's what he's saying
oh yeah yeah exactly
I [ __ ] you Jimmy yeah we [ __ ] yeah we
[ __ ] you Jimmy yeah during the Big
Lebowski never been in a huge big
lebowski myself actually I watched it on
Christmas morning at 3:00 a.m. wrapping
presents one year but your family has
always been a Coen Brothers family yeah
but the weird thing is that Lebowski
when I was growing up did not get much
of any play that I saw and when I first
watched it I was completely alone and I
was like watching yourself elite yeah I
was touching myself and I was at least
in my late teens or early 20s or
something so it took me a long time to
see it and it was of my own volition I
get even though yeah my family is big
into the Cohens oh wow okay so there's
some super chats you're the totally mist
over here my dad you know we just we
just don't want to only make it we were
trying to include everyone as much as
you can't Blade Runner Blade Runner is a
film that seems to progressively get
worse for me every time I really don't
like Blade Runner didn't like as much
the second time okay I don't know how to
comply I did like that film as a child
and now I both recognize what isn't good
about it but I also recognize what it
wants to be and I'm very torn between
the two this is how long we take on
questions yes
it was all here if we take so long
answering questions we got it we gotta
speed round stir questions everybody
gets a super chat in and everyone gets a
1-minute answer
oh yeah Michael Mac thank you so much
for contribute to the super chat thank
you thank you Michael Mac thank you
reminds me of a Big Mac oh my god before
I was a pescetarian I ate a lot of Big
Macs I didn't like the Resident Evil
movies as video game movies but watching
again as action movies are great PS I
thought Avengers and one was amazing
first time but just good on re-watch
okay okay okay you know what yes I'll
give it to you I think the Resident Evil
movies are fun can't be stupid silly
films I'll give it to you Avengers one I
still feel like that movie was [ __ ]
grand and great and amazing for like the
first three years it was and then over
time I started to see the flaws with the
first Avengers movie I will definitely I
think I really did have what do they
call that yeah rose-colored glasses just
could not see what was that yeah it's
everything I wanted but then eventually
I was able to see what was up with it it
happens when you grow old and mature for
example part of maturing is doing better
for the environment
mmm pescetarian yep get not better for
the fish never lose your nerd thank you
so much for your super chat my homey
read his chest no matter how many times
I watched last Jedi I still don't like
it and yes pulp fiction - never lose
your nerd is actually samuel l.jackson
according to John Humphrey right reading
that stay the [ __ ] inside book I'm sorry
you don't and
Pulp Fiction is one you don't okay Wow
last Jedi I can't blame yet because the
world is [ __ ] bizarre with that movie
but pulp fiction really can't ever get
on board with that but do you like put
any Tarantino films at all I can see if
you were like introduced to Tarantino
with Kill Bill and then you went to pulp
fiction you're like the [ __ ] is this is
boring but if you started but I feel
like started with Kill Bill and then
went to ball fiction I could see you
being kind of bored with pulp fiction
now unless you really love Kill Bill Vol
two more and then you went to Paul
fiction then I could see that sad now
trying to remember the order I saw the
Tarantino movies in because I know the
first one I saw in a theater was Kill
Bill 2 but I feel like I was younger
when you first showed me Reservoir Dogs
it may have been killed bill 2 but I
think it was Roberta
I mean Pulp Fiction is a pretty high
movie so I could see that happening
Hobby er thank you never lose your nerd
you never lose your nerd keep it don't
no matter what anyone less of course it
cost you a job or respect from a woman
you are attracted to
or if losing it give it up could just
get you ahead you know you're never
here's the best truth you won't ever be
happy being who you are so you got to
pretend and lie and start a YouTube
channel and then put up this facade and
then go on social media and create an
Instagram account that makes it look
like life is grand when really we're all
dead on the inside we're just here to
prop up the big machine we call society
and the economy I just want to make sure
people are having a good time escaping
from the situation right now by talking
about this subject talk about corruption
in politics Javier Vargas thank you so
much dude very sweetie I'm pretty sweet
too sweet I say did not like casino ooh
copier Vargas I wish we weren't so late
to this comment because he's the only
one who properly did what I said yes
it's very clear he said did not casino
did like Batman and Robin
19:07 in China
so he was saying at first he did not
like casino but then eventually liked it
did like Batman and Robin eventually
didn't like it
Casino was it's a that's an interesting
relationship my god that movie because
sometimes I go back and forth on whether
or not I prefer that over a good fun
yeah right and I feel like that
conversation is starting to come up a
little bit more often now that you know
what I'm it's been a second since I've
seen Casino and I had that experience
growing up when when you first showed me
both those movies you lent them to me
and I remembered liking casino more yeah
and now I'm at the moment yeah I kind of
took teeters but I'd end up with
Goodfellas a lot more often than I used
I don't know and I don't know what it
was because like isn't casino um more
you know deliberately paced movie uh
yeah I mean it's a little bit more
meandering in the first half and then in
the last half a like first half is just
all-access and fun and the last half is
just let's just but I think it feels a
little bit more contained because you're
mainly focused on three people and
watching how those three destroyed each
other that makes good sense whereas like
Goodfellas is much more expansive and
bigger and even though it's more
singularly focused on Henry Hill I don't
know there's there's something is maybes
because it's like it's so much DeNiro
and Pesci in there but yeah that's my
thing Ashton Bailey thank you so much
you're keeping us sane by hanging out
with us on this Friday night
Ashton John read the comment oh what
have I been doing read it in an accent
that always perks you up thank you guys
for keeping me sin Lola I didn't like
Wally the first time I watched it twelve
years ago no it is one of my favorite
movies I'm a fat bastard Hey there has
been so much random Austin Powers ever
since you started talking about yes and
not only that but I saw Andrea Bocelli
ad on a back of a bus yesterday and I'm
a huge Andrea Bocelli so we were at one
song what are the odds that he's all
over this bus I took pictures and
everything
Wally ah Wally I think is one of the
best
sar films yeah it's definitely one of
the most innovative I rewatched that
last year on Disney Plus and on I did
not remember how [ __ ] dark that movie
you actually get that oh yeah it's a
bleak future I realized like when there
are all the fat people are like piling
over like in and crowds and the ship is
like getting all [ __ ] up and there's
like on top of each other it's kind of
gross yeah it's really it's gross that's
so weird where that comes mine gross
yeah cuz it's also because it's not even
about the stature fully it's about the
lethargy and the attached [ __ ] fat
shaming a little air look how sadly
detached all these people are and now
they can't even fend for themselves yeah
but hey that's a good I mean Wally I'm
glad you like it now I'm glad you came
to your senses but I'll say to you son
okay you we're saying we love the NHS is
that like the Health Service NHS oh yeah
because there are different
NHS's but I feel like they're your soul
care 1999 because people keep commenting
that and I feel like this has something
to do with our health care system so
what's NHS isn't it like the national
health care service for National Health
Service or health care for all UK
citizens based on their need for medical
care and their ability to pay for it who
the [ __ ] wouldn't want the NHS I know
but there's an NHS here that's like the
National Security Rule [ __ ] is that what
I've become because I want to pay $600 a
month health insurance for poor service
I want to pay $300 a month for my high
oscar insurance and then pay $50 a copay
I want to pay more on top of getting
there after I've already given you so
much money over the years like it's
great I love it it's great system they
all have to fuss to said your name
that's what that was 30 minutes ago he
asked for that ma'am you got to keep up
with this guy hi hey we're back look at
that Joker isn't the greatest Alana's
back
Lana Pico what che Lana thanks for being
in your house too ye doing hi guys
hi Lana wasn't a big fan of a my fall
out the first time around but a second
even got past Tom Cruise's tiny miss
took her six Mission Impossible movies
to get past Tom Cruise's tiny itself
it's only by the sixth one that you can
see how much he has grown I've never
noticed how small Tom Cruise's and
people point that out but I've never
been a distracting factor to me oh yeah
I've usually been pulled into whichever
movie I'm watching enough that I'd
forget to look well it does it have
something to do
I mean maybe because you've been I'm
gonna speak for all women here because I
have every right to why are you always
on about women's den so is it because
you're a woman who dates around and then
so you're normally women want a guy
who's taller or at least their height
that you really take notice of it is
that what it is are you being sexist
towards Tom Cruise I'm not allowed to
call women sexist no I think it doesn't
that sexist to me to do that isn't it no
they're exempt you're being a sec yes
you're being a sexist for say sure I've
heard this argument transpired you know
it's funny though this made me Alana
thank you keep up the great Instagram
yeah yeah and stay stay real a she we
follow her state corporeal and the
mission impossible I gotta tell you
Mission Impossible too I was all about
when it first came out that's the call
you have Joey there there we go there
now movie for this category is a twist
here's a twist and it's not as dramatic
as I'm I - but am i - I loved back in
the day and it is is aged terribly ma'am
I three I didn't dislike but I didn't
love it on first watch upon rewatching
the last time we did like a marathon L
like it's it's one of my top of the
series if not the top like so that one
really appreciated in value even though
I already liked it am i oh yeah [ __ ] I
hate Mission Impossible I hate that this
second movie I love that franchise but
Hey yeah and now I like don't include my
thing is when I look back on and I'm
like how did I engage with this as a kid
because there's not even that much
action or cool stuff
well that's the thing you sit through a
board but when you watch the action
that's all you remember it's all at the
very end yeah that's all at the end and
all those dubs Carter Lovejoy thank you
so much Thank You Lana for for doing
that I hope you're staying safe in home
to hope your tinder profile is doing
great
Carl Lovejoy I hope your Bumble account
is doing great I made our people online
dating right now
I've been online day yeah are you guys
dating if you're single right make a
mental connection but I can't imagine I
feel like you could only make a friend I
have watch what baby are you there
Olivia oh can you come here
oh it's taking a minute to get here I
need your help with something it's
urgent can she hear you are you kidding
me playing Final Fantasy 7 she is shouts
out to Brianna white do we have a mental
connection see told you why stand
correct
jeepers Christ how are you guys
developing mental connections it's gone
our minds go so does everything else we
have such a similar sense I'm sorry I
made the biggest sin as a kid I feel
like we end up doing these live streams
isn't it always started there's a thing
that we always say before we do the live
streams as a matter of fact here's I'm
going to try to do I'm gonna write it
down I don't want say too much time do
well okay how about we just try to say
it okay I always say let's just make
these people happy
let's just make them happy that's always
the focus before we do it let's just try
this just make you guys happy everyone's
bored like that's where our mind always
goes and then we go live yeah that's
like the first thing we always the
mantra yeah
yeahlet's that's our whole focus let's
keep everybody company and give them
some fun then I think about for a half
hour
our ramblings just become for us well
it's a conversation man we were talking
back and forth we have the microphone
power but that's not thing a live
podcast would be fun yeah is I think
we'd be good at a topic like like with
it life is an audience like like talking
like literally like instead of you just
saying a sane sentence to us I was
reading it we have you guys like really
give your opinion back and forth mm-hmm
and then have the shy people be like
really uncomfortable that'd be great
you know really shy on the mic um I made
the biggest sin as a kid when I said cat
and saw cat in the hat' 2003 oh thank
god you clarified I was like are you
talking about a 1989 edition starring
Bill Berger you're talking about the
2022 sequel that has the same name for
some reason is the best movie ever now I
hate it so much and I'm still going to
hell well how old were you hey hey
that's how God works yet is actually an
emotion you're punished all sins are
equal and once you get that first one
it's done well I'm here to tell you
you're not going to hell you're going to
heaven because you have absolved
yourself by coming around and realize
that's a bad movie but Mike Myers Austin
Powers trilogy that's something right
there and the love you still funny as
[ __ ] I love those Austin Powers movies
and very much a series I'm surprised has
not gotten a revamp at all late don't I
thought it ended perfectly it did
I'm just hours in the meets you movement
will be a hilarious see there's got to
be I feel there's some kind of comedy to
perform from that because so much
vulgarity in Austin Powers is so
terrible at talking with women Austin
gets woke because the only movie that
really dealt with the way how
inappropriate he isn't how out of touch
out of touch he is with the way he
comments on woman was the first movie
with Elizabeth Hurley
because of the comment she makes but
even still in that movie she's still
like oh like there's like five minutes
where she's saying don't treat me that
way
but then after watch like oh my god
that's the first words y'all want to do
it oh damn we missed some Ethan Holgate
Ethan have you guys seen God which is
two gentlemen have not no do people make
fun of your name meats and Holgate well
with appreciate the super check what
would they make fun of it as we will
make fun of you now well once you get
through the gate you get into Ethan's
hole that's right
that's right you all make you horny ho
guys how does how does he think Keith is
teeth clean with a whole gate oh that
would have been way more appropriate
than mine they're both good in their own
way one's clean and ones dirty oh my god
we got this is the super chat speed
round
Nathan Kelly thank you so much Nathan
Kelly they VC Ned Kelly overrated one
movie that I adore at the moment that I
saw three times in the cinah market - it
was 1917 and I'm getting in a 4k soon it
was so simple but impactful thank you
for bringing that up I'm gonna bring up
something that there was generally I
watch more movies than John and then
there was a period around December where
John was suddenly watching way more
movies than me
yeah there was that window and and then
he saw night he one day he came in and
apparently he had already seen 19:17
twice and I hadn't hadn't known that I
was like you really should watch 1970
it's pretty great and I was met with
this feeling of like anger and jealousy
like why did he watch 19:17 before me
rationally he came between 17 and i lord
it over you for weeks
you little [ __ ]
you saw 1979 receded twice what do you
mean yeah you know I'd find out you
person start us at these reactions
cinema like when the [ __ ] did you watch
this
why wasn't I told you was gonna go watch
this movie ninety-nine percent the time
I'm bringing up let's go watch a movie
what the hell John it was I think my
sister took me or something I can't
remember
Oh sibling bonding it's creepy mother
you know I was messed don't bother your
siblings especially during this time if
you live at home creepy outside as much
as you can
Thank You Nathan Kelly thank you soup
night
no no that's Suge Knight Suge nothing
soup night I mean it might be better to
be called soup night at this moment real
rejects versus the pride who's weighing
that is a Schmo down question if only I
could just quickly remember who the
pride is on the Schmo down reversed I
think so isn't that Rachel well because
as we know there are people names and as
well by the team names you know what I
was [ __ ] nicest [ __ ] and then at one
point [ __ ] I'm not swirling the match
one point Rachel did say [ __ ]
to us and I was like oh well you know I
intentionally avoided certain tactics
coy said to do that I did not do because
I was being nice so get ready for a good
clean man warrior alerts for you I can't
reveal who or else I'm gonna get a nasty
text from a nasty man game nasty
Christian alright I can't I got a bad
nasty bad ok ok we did sky oh my god
have we caught up I think we might we oh
Michael I think we've caught up are we
on dreamcatcher
alright dreamcatcher we're on track my
surnames uh I just want to take a second
get off my chair dreamchaser he wants to
be a dancer dude you should tell by his
photo everyone take his icon there and
green-screen it with something make it a
challenge
Jim that's a great promo pick for
yourself by the way is your name
dreamchaser is that your actual like
just directing name watch Thor the dark
world after Avengers an game liked it
you know I'm wonderful vengers endgame
has that effect on some of the previous
MCU movies because it did so much
especially cuz endgame weirdly does a
lot it's going back to Thor Theodoric or
literally walks through that movie a
couple of times yeah you can watch Thor
and go also there because it was pretty
much the most essential one for the Thor
journey with the stone reality stone so
I wonder if it does upon that reasoning
mate Thor the dark world a better movie
to watch you just drop a good point
thank you dreamchaser get ready sweetie
you get ready for that reira view thank
you oh my god we got someone in here
saying after we watching The Matrix it
didn't age well
tella I die we watch The Matrix like
every two years and it gets better with
time dela the funky homosapien not agree
with you on that what's your favorite
superhero um what what's your favorite
superhero John my favorite superhero
would either be I mean like classics we
talk in spider-man for sure
but um my favorite superhero from the DC
side maybe Spectre I know I can get I
told you you were afraid of bottoming
out so I was like I'm gonna keep the
energy and then when you bottom out I'll
get really ratchet you know that's how
we do that's how we do a professional
you are the professional yeah I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna I'm not gonna crash
on the live so you're Leon the profound
I'm gonna crash here Ethan says my
girlfriend is there awesome I'm so into
that Ethan you're on didn't like Step
Brothers till I rewatched it that's a
fascinating Hillary that's a fascinating
movie you know step stepbrother yo
Johnny take it away keep over-talking
movie that somehow I feel like has
doesn't have a good reception as a film
and yet so many people find it hilarious
and quoted like despite its quality as a
movie that's
and I'm one of those people yeah I don't
really like that movie but when I quote
it I think it's one of the funniest
movies of all time I almost feel like if
you if you reek if you cut up that movie
and released it as a series of little
YouTube webisodes it might be perfect
yeah I'm right and I that's a great
great analysis John that's why you've
been hired by the higher-ups at the real
RIA they're Doctor Who creature thank
you Jason B that's really sweet of you
to say that by the way who are twos is
an amazing movie every person on the
planet 8r3 was alright I love this
straight to the point ones here
I like Batman and Robin now I don't like
it
all I got to do is talk for it our in a
live stream and then my voice enough
where I could possibly do with it I mean
I got it I got either get sicker or wake
up to if I wake up without enough sleep
I get the gravel or Nissa liver what's
up dude gave you a super sweet shout-out
recently I'm gonna do some squats for
you we did a super sweet why are you
doing squats because usually when you
kneel down I start doing the squats and
I haven't started squatting squat that's
John's weird John's my video game
follower
I kneel and he does this like weird
thing I'm like that's not really helping
but thanks just in case your sister's
not really doing much I'm here for
psychological support what the [ __ ] how
do I have no idea you all we're doing
this tonight because we don't make early
enough announcements so I thought these
are on Saturdays want to mix it up just
for a night I am heated oh I bet she's I
bet she's heated right now for a little
yeah a little someone who's that come on
John you know I'm talking about your
John as well she's thinking about you
think about John John Oh John John while
he's on the job yeah well in the gas
station the gas station John yeah oh man
I just saw ten people
I'll make you all a deal we can get if
we can get 200 concurrent eyes in here
if we hit 200 I will share a surprise
with all of you what is that
can't tell you because it's surprise for
you guys how it works Anisa thank you so
much you're so sweet
it reveals you gotta check out the
native shoutout you got it it's not even
real move mat beer is so on about this
[ __ ] make sure it's I think it's got
chicken in it even if it's not very
natural at all random a nice channel
remember your face I remember that
handsome oh look at that handsome mug
it's you you look like a guy who's
caught between time periods
yeah like the lead singer like the lead
singer of Mumford & Sons you do look
like him and then hands caught between
time Carrie found ex machina boring but
now it's in my top 100 do you have a top
100 I've never made it on one never made
I don't know if I could or no why
because if I ever watch a new movie that
I love 100 every [ __ ] movie yeah it's
a problem it's a big problem but Thank
You random Andy's channel you look like
a more chiseled mr. incredible yeah I
loved ex machina by the way so good
taste on you Oh ex machina is an amazing
film mm-hmm my top 100 inception yeah
something is still crap I don't know a
movie my girlfriend's talking about Oh
somebody hates Amadeus in the chat
that's a hot take Archer PA oh is that
Philadelphia production assistant Archer
John T rain best Archer impression which
is an impression of H Jud Benjamin oh my
god that's great a reject nation I have
two picks for movies I liked at a pod
rewatch disliked I liked x-men origins
Wolverine the first time I saw Zod again
about a year later and I hated it I
haven't heard him in a while so it could
be better it's not bad it's really not
bad don't cuz yeah that moment I was
like oh what I'm not scared to do oh
you're the one who liked it the first
no not you this our archers the first
one is the one who likes it thank you
for contributing Archer
do you remember when we saw x-men
origins Wolverine true what we did that
day what did we do that
I remember what we did goodnight let's
hear it refresh me I worked at a hot dog
restaurant called vicious dogs that's
right
former meat-eater former hot dog chef
yeah Wow Aryan former part of the
problem you made the greggy veggie you
are already on that on that game now are
you need a greggy veggie if you guys are
the living california la gota vicious
dogs by agretti veggie I created that
[ __ ] it's real dan merle fromm screen
jock Oh Dan Merle Fame damn Merle yeah
him and his girlfriend Maura what to
screen junkies because I recommended it
and they loved it they can't go now
because you know closed because of the
quarantine situation anyway oh I could
spend hours as Wolverine I worked there
and there was a woman who worked there
named Jessica and she was a sty she like
she's aspiring stylist I believe oh I do
remember this and then we are a week was
origin we got tickets to go watch x-men
origins Wolverine we used to have a
t-shirt company that one of our failed
business ventures called updated apparel
I still have some prototypes our tag
line get updated you see why I failed
and then we had John to this Wolverine
design I wore the shirt and then she
spent hours doing my hair look like
Wolverine so I was like decked out like
we're gonna watch a fan oh boy was it
boring I went from looking like the most
Pumped Up fan at the haters to oh I
really wish I didn't look like it was
not good not good and it didn't even
like do better upon its trailer yeah
which at least in the affects diverse
the trailers better than that movie but
oh now is and that of all the days to
get dressed up that that's gotta hurt
yeah that was bad
that's a
Pistor - it's like my first cosplay I've
ever done and my only cosplay fight when
I think about it is too traumatic
he said you have two movies yeah X both
times
Erik Horstmann Horstman Erik I swear to
god you better change your thigh if you
guys haven't heard yet he is the man the
only man in the world with a tattoo hope
the real rejects look big it's a big
[ __ ] tattoo it's a large one
thank you so much Erik thank you Xanadu
best movie ever on acid sober not so
good oh I thought he was I thought he
was confused about his mental state at
the st. best movie ever on acid sober
not so good what Xanadu um Oh how do you
describe Xanadu it's like a big musical
dance disco and I'm probably butchering
this though I am NOT I don't know the
Santa booze and science yeah there you
go Olivia newton-john oh oh
we should patch this trailer through
this yeah yeah no this does not look
good huh yeah okay I got a friend who
loves Xanadu oh god I've never seen this
except for for these moments and
whatever she is shown actually this was
like a total blast
this looks like a great thing to trip
acid on oh my god and I totally have
acid in them in the bathroom oh yeah
that's it before I keep it underneath
the toilet okay that's the place yeah
you want to go on a ride you guys know
that's where I keep the acid oh my good
really helps with boring ass times right
now all right so where we at all right
so okay okay all right
Jordan x-men apocalypse and now an ya
meet you there extra boxes one of the
movies that I I was like I don't think
this bad everyone says but I also don't
give a [ __ ] sorry watch it it's not
terrible but it's just like so trite
it's just like so run-of-the-mill that
it's frustrating I got I got a shout out
this question from a crazy gamer cool
Russia bro did you guys watch any game
No if we waited we're waiting for phase
5 to be done wise Carter Lovejoy a man
who is super chad has twice a day saying
cancel the real rejects what the [ __ ]
o-haru that is hurroo hurroo one of our
top patrons man love that mother
apparently her ooze fan whoever who was
in the room with listening to your Code
Geass like they heard your shout out and
everyone's like really I heard him being
spoken about in your video so now Haru
is famous to his friends and family all
right guys we're gonna we're gonna
oh whoa we got on for an hour 13 in this
said we need to watch other people's
lives I mean we did love it this is just
so fun live streams are an example of
Megan John being in love with the sound
of their own voice there's nobody to
interrupt us so we can only assume we're
doing a great job and all we hear is a
laugh track in the background and
whenever we make any the most mild of
jokes what we hear is our audience going
it's every Mary with children and every
one of us enters that door people you
know not single oh yeah that's Mary with
children that's the okay John just yeah
you know it's a little yes and for you
Lois courage thank you
Louie B is that a dog next to a Taco
Bell box that's its box that contains a
serious attitude can you imagine if the
Box on your mailbox was I think it's a
caution contains like Jesus Christ what
am i eating this chains boiled meats I
made the mistake of playing the hit man
video game can't a campaign patient zero
right to kill anyone it got infected
many died what is the worst movie or TV
series to watch right now I think the
worst movie to watch right now I mean if
you're feeling trapped in home I would
say human centipede would be the worst
movie to watch
rest in peace dieter laser
it would be the best movie to watch
right now because I just remember that
cuz of Johnson yesterday that's right I
take it back I know she's gonna be
edited right I think I think the joke is
fine he knew a movie he was making and
if you've seen part three I think he'd
be fine I guess I would also say the
stand don't want to stand I mean
honestly I don't think it's I don't know
see there's one argument to be made and
we actually talked about this at our
podcast on patreon recently of total
plug total plug the question was heaven
pay a dollar we were talking about
because I was saying I don't I wouldn't
want to watch movies that are about
quarantine situations or things like
contagion or not twelve Monkeys but
what's the one with the monkey outbreak
breaking her outbreak zombie movies are
one thing isn't like it's [ __ ]
ridiculous zombies but like movies that
seem to really be like a real quarantine
situation I watch I wouldn't want to
watch that but I feel like there's an
argument to be made for that of well is
the movies portray that as worse than
what is going on in a lot of ways unless
you're someone who's dealing with it
like really has to has the virus or know
someone who died or did lose someone
then can't be worse but if it's not like
like for me yeah I I might know some
people who have lost some people but I
haven't personally lost like any one of
my family do this so if I watched it I
don't know just be like I don't want to
be reminded a real life or it might be
the effect of well it's not that bad for
me so I have nothing to come I don't
feel like I have anything to complain
about I don't that people have a way of
worse and all things considered you know
it's like not a really a big deal if we
have to just not hang out well and
there's - I think it depends on how you
experience catharsis - because I think
some people like to get catharsis from
yeah
you know I think some people glean
catharsis from watching a similar
situation that you know movies give you
a certain way to interface with stress
in a safe way but then yeah I think
there are some other people who just
would really prefer the light and the
brevity ah good call you know maybe a
little both uh miss uh oh thank you so
much that's a major major [ __ ] one
right there it's a nipple and yes answer
your question Kimberly Johnson yeah game
theory the matpat channel he's really
known yeah dan is the head editor for
game theory tiny tiny Channel very
limited success wait we got deer I Derek
Mitchell and Rosa Parrish Owen up here
but Anissa no so is it I haven't seen
the wrong full-time I don't know Kara
correct in a story I wrote after you
thank you nice that is such a [ __ ]
that thank you that's it's a major
contribution this is how you buy our
love and Nestle it's working we have no
dignity type what you want to do you
want me to eat Greg sock fine oh [ __ ]
he'll do not really know you know no not
really answering not really answering
the question but kind of am when I was
younger never understood the harry
potter volta Mort storyline of a piece
of him being in Harry but when I got
older and watched them all over again I
finally got it
homoerotic a lot of people don't really
pick up on that yeah Harry and Tom
shouldn't have denied their look but I
think if someone if Ninja Panda channel
ever did an unnecessary censorship for
Harry Potter a lot of people will go oh
my god I I don't think this is a
necessary censorship I think this is an
exposing video just how homoerotic the
harry and voldemort
situation well I mean the thing they
never explore in these Harry Potter
books and I mean JK Rowling be out here
tweeting all kinds of random canon
information and they never interface
with happy
Wizarding World get busy you never hear
about there's gotta be like freaky sex
toys for magician I'm sure if you tweet
actually a rallying and it sounds like a
good idea to make her book sound more
progressive she'll put out a tweet and
change the cannon right then and there
very sex positive good tweet oh yeah
yeah that guy's totally Jewish - [ __ ]
wherever they were and they just
magicked it away [ __ ] on the floor which
is a real tweak real twist
thank you so much Anissa Oh Nisa you're
so sweet a nice when we go to Texas we
are getting beyond burgers together oh
swear to God
beyond barbecue let's do that we're
gonna hang with your family and we're
gonna make them super uncomfortable you
know why cuz they have no idea who we
are Nisa and we're gonna go to a house
and go hey we're two dudes that your
daughter met on the Internet how you
doing now how do we say your name
Proctor we say your name properly
they're neither come over here give us
some hugs yeah either way we love you
and we know how to spell it
none of those eyes will surely that eyes
we did not miss you're super shot Suge
Knight Suge Knight let's let's read it
again just to be safe we didn't remember
because I say I know I said Sookie never
something soup night I said soup night
yeah pride I don't know you're just
gonna have to watch well we're gonna do
for everyone a super check what we're
gonna do is make sure we're gonna go
through all these at the very end yes
it's to make sure yeah we did it yes
anybody would not want to be those
people okay okay let's go down let's see
some more let's go Dragonball Evolution
in Batman and Robin are the worst Oh
Laura Martinez so nice to see you dude
don't don't don't knock Dragonball
Evolution okay that's Justin Chatwin's
best work oh my god mr. nobody from The
Fast and Furious mr. nobody I feel like
I would meet you here on this one movie
I didn't like at first but now is one of
my favorites is fury road movies that
don't like on rewatch was signs okay
well first off mr. nobody you are no
long
nobody you are a major somebody in our
hearts now buddy
Thank You mr. nobody fury road is a film
I really [ __ ] appreciate the hell out
of but I don't love it like everyone
else and I wonder if i rewatch it that
I'll be that guy I could see that
happening with that movie up I think I
finally get it now this is one of the
greatest movies ever made I mean there
is a quality to it that isn't exactly
maybe what you expect just cuz the
trailer is so perfect and like the the
storytelling pace and style is a little
different from that portrayal because
they give you so many awesome money
shots in that trailer but I'd be curious
to hear your thoughts on another viewing
but ya know I can meet you there mr.
nobody and signs admittedly it took me a
few viewings to finally get what people
didn't like a pony
because I really enjoyed that movie and
I still do as a matter of fact I think
there's a lot that people just don't
latch on to you what makes it so good
and while I see what's stupid about it
now I think there's still plenty of
amazing things about that film and but
it did take me a while to really pick up
on oh I get it that's why that's why the
swing-away marrow things dumb oh the
water that's that's why I've always been
a little there is one massive issue with
the water that I think is a legitimate
uh
plot hole but IIIi didn't mind it as a
tribute to War of the Worlds fair enough
you know we're behind us a super jazz do
it we take Sunday driving through a live
stream oh no you gotta find your
goldfish Robert you're freaking out
about your goldfish if you're looking
for your goldfish you're freaking out
you shouldn't be here you should be
looking you should be looking for your
goldfish the goldfish is not in your
screen it's it's in it's in water how
bout your Glines you get away or hit it
jump out of the bowl do you have a big
tank what kind of stitch we talking here
Oh Britney Oh what is this sticker where
is that sticker here it is oh it's a
little dancey pear
God says you are amazing you're amazing
what are you talking to me John oh yeah
we got a we got amazing because ego is
not shared ego is exclusive mm-hmm well
yeah and we count ego by dollars really
is important who this is directed we
can't split
all right let's backtrack here a little
bit beckon in trekking oh my god what is
it who is so many oh my Anisa also said
also can't wait to get our tattoos after
this quarantine is over and I travel to
Los Angeles so we could get them
together y'all travel to Texas I am also
a pescetarian but sure fellow
pescetarian the numbers are growing even
though your examples were really drawn
to John looks like we have a little bit
more in common eyes yeah
fact that we're helping the world out
with our pescetarian abilities and John
what is this tattoo you're gonna be
getting with a Nyssa oh it's uh oh yeah
based on the whole gas station thing
from last time I decided that all three
of us we're gonna get you know like a
little gas light that comes up on your
car - when you need to fill up mmm we're
all gonna get that that's great man it's
gonna be like in Harry Potter we were
like if we touch it with our with our
wands then like each one will burn and
we'll be like okay we gotta meet up you
to do that you're part of that you made
up the joke I know I made up the joke
but now you got to commit to it okay hey
hey she has given enough for you to get
a tattoo um possibly let's go cheap who
cares I'm gonna - well a lot of shops
have of 150 minimum I'll chip in I'll
chimney there you don't need a fancy
tattoo yeah I'll just get a penance and
a needle and just do it myself can be
wrong about going cheap on a tattoo
you're gonna be going wrong with you
know getting your skin punctured
thousands of times
Louisburg Thank You Anissa um Anissa you
are so sweet
Lewis barrage Burrage barrage says
I really didn't like Cloud Atlas the
first time long and confusing really
enjoyed it the second time nuance
references Chinese Hugo Weaving probably
wouldn't be allowed these days Chinese a
lot of it I don't know Lucy K is getting
out stand-up specials and being a hit on
the internet with it maybe a Chinese
Hugo Weaving still has another shot in
the sequel the cloud Alice for all those
yellow facing hands actually what's
funny with Cloud Atlas and I think
what's funny with that movie
I haven't actually Johnny you were
failing a chat and somebody requested it
for trailers when I saw Cloud Atlas I
remembered it took me a long cuz I saw
in the theaters and it took me a while
in case you guys haven't seen Cloud
Atlas just a quick refresher it's it
focuses on like I forget how many
storylines I'm gonna say six just for
the sake of argument so there's like six
storylines that's focusing on that all
take place or in different time periods
and are different genres and they don't
really connect but they and some of them
are and so you have the Wachowski su
directed it and then another director so
you got these very different storylines
you're cutting to and they're that feel
like six completely different movies and
then Tom Hanks is in a few and them
Halle bears and a few of them and it was
kind of a hard watch the first half of
it was actually a really difficult thing
to adjust to and it was a little
annoying and frustrating and then
somewhere around the midpoint of
watching it I I was able to settle into
it and I really started to love that
film and I think it's actually quite
underrated and once you can relax into
the weird groove of the movie as it
becomes a very rewarding and a very
unique experience it's very ambitious
what they set out to do not an easy
watch but I think on a second time
watching it would be a fun thing to do
but I would never make anyone sit
through it because it's too much to ask
I don't want to take that on although
you're making me want to take that on so
I'm curious to see it it's a great way I
think it's a lot of fun ya know huh fun
is not the word I have heard nap no it
is trust me
no no tipsy Top Gun yeah
take it away John Top Gun was a movie I
enjoyed growing up but not anymore and
the sleazy bar from it is in San Diego
we should Niraj when you come to
California we're gonna play volleyball
in speedos together just you and I
one-on-one
serious match John will be oiling us up
and it's gonna be a great time great
minds now is about to say that I would
love for you to all up Niraj oh yeah I
feel like I'd be pretty good at that I
can give a decent like oil massage yeah
have you given an oil massage no well
but you know I'm a decent misogynist
I've been told by who you know a lot of
people friends neighbors strangers
sister sister mother father extended
family cousins uncles aunts you know
massage all your family family masseuse
every your family must be where's Ben
that is the that's how you know your
stream is successful we always reach
this point in the in the live stream
like what is this live stream I Oh
Flatliner
87 liner that's a bath I want to hop in
hey handsome men thanks for another
conversation I love when we do stupid
[ __ ] and then I read the comment that
really supports what we're doing and I
keep my spirits up after being trapped
at home working all men took me a long
time to come around to hereditary what
horror subgenres do you enjoy Oh horror
western children western children's or
Western children or real slow burn
Sergio Leone horror with a children's
tone educational Dadaist horror is is
one of my favorites Mexican Mexican
[ __ ] Spanish scat horror thank you so
much for that major super chat dude
that's a really major contribution thank
you and by the way I think you are way
more handsome than both of us oh come on
my hair tied up I'm not a very appealing
guy with my hair tied up but it makes
for a much more comfortable time being
in a hot room I mean I like it but
whatever John everyone loves your hair
oh my god John's hair what would you be
without your hair you'd be nothing
without your suit that's what I have to
learn is the hair was within me I don't
need it for whatever it provides me or
so I really love horror comedies I think
they go together really well and I've
seen a lot of horror that's either like
super [ __ ] bleak and depressing and
about grief or something that looks
there's something more a little more fun
but it's not exactly a horror comedy
like a [ __ ] get out there are more
fun they're entertaining fast pace but
they're not like you know cohort
comedies I feel like we haven't had a
horror comedy like a great one in a long
time that's like a minute it's was the
last meet I mean zombie lands pretty
[ __ ] good yeah like some doubles have
but one that is like that's still way
more comedy than horror yeah and it's
been a long like Shaun of the Dead was
like the last major great one I think
the one that really had me a lot of
other people in the horror community say
Tucker and Dale but um but yes it has
been a hot minute since we've had like a
true horror comedy I love a good horror
comedy I like a good body horror yeah I
really like surreal like hypnotic trippy
horror the more surreal the more
unsettling and the human [ __ ] really
scares me the most human [ __ ] you know
when people poop oh yeah no yes if my
girlfriend ever leaves a single dot in
the toilet a poo dot a beating and of me
she beats the [ __ ] out of me because I
try to attack her
she overpowers me and man she has curbed
me it is bad what was I trying to
explain when people put some come here
we have reader [ __ ] I what I imagine at
this point in the livestreams is is what
Stanley Kubrick would try to get his
actors to the point of Tears and
delirium where you're just not thinking
anymore and you're just coming fro and
ever is coming out of your heart the
human the human [ __ ] is like horror that
is based in like grounded human actions
you know horror about depraved human
beings doing depraved human plausible
things what scares me the most about
watching like a man with a reality show
running for president one day
totally yeah I get that dude that's the
most scary man can you imagine no no I
can't school no I can't luckily I can't
that's a good thing that's never
happened here never thing called denial
it's an amazing River not in denial
you can't prove it you can't prove on in
denial way I stole that joke from a show
oh oh what joke did I still have from
comment below I know
30 rock as Lemmon says is she from
Africa she is in denial
I feel like that's a pretty like
well-worn public archive joke now not
anymore
long as the Tina Fey this is the most
eyes we've got her on this livestream
today you came in at the right time
welcome to delirious get them to 200 a
surprise if you can get to 200 before
it's over hey geared towards sync thank
you for the superjet okay guys follow
geared towards sync he's not asking this
I'm telling I'm just requesting you do
this follow him on Instagram you're
gonna love the content he post there he
has this amazing service where he puts
custom designs on these on these of as
the fans I believe yeah vans shoes and
they are [ __ ] beautiful like he's
like one with like Eminem in post
Malone's face all there it's free and I
asked him to do a custom one for me I
don't want to reveal what it is but when
it comes in the mail he's saying John
you're gonna want to be here for when I
open it yeah I'm gonna open it on camera
I asked him to not send me any pre
photos in advance
I just want to see it for the first time
on camera and I'm you guys are gonna
love I know he's gonna deliver on it
because I've seen the other designs they
look [ __ ] beautiful but so thank you
geared towards saying era and Derek
Mitchell what's up buddy
dee Mac thanks for being here dude and
thanks for contributing to super chat
here
he says going to change gears a bit
better call Saul is the best show on TV
right now thoughts better call Saul is
the best show on TV right now I am a
that's the only [ __ ] like [ __ ] guy I
don't even know when I bought it on
Amazon because I'm too impatient to wait
for it to come out on Netflix so I
bought this the latest season so every
time there's a new episode comes out
like on a Tuesday or Wednesday and I
make time to watch that [ __ ] it is so
addicting and I would say honestly like
the first couple seasons are if you were
to compare like season 1 in season 2
with like the first season and second
season of Breaking Bad I don't think
like it's better than Breaking Bad but I
think when I'm looking at the show as a
whole versus a of Breaking Bad I think
they're equal I really like it's it's a
much different show and a different
build but it gets intense it gets
gripping it gets like for a show that's
just a pitched originally as a prequel
it is surprising as [ __ ] it so I I
really love that show and I think it
should be talked about more I think it
says first couple seasons were so
different than Breaking Bad but it's
really reached some like dark gritty
territory yeah I think you guys really
loved that's when I got to catch up on
because that show does have a special a
special tone and special quality and
they're both like I think both of those
shows it would be interesting if you
could average out a way to compare them
properly but they both take such a
different approach to just character
depth as the motivator for all this you
know right all these event like they're
both really character oriented but also
crazy and out there yeah that's true
that's true
alright Ashton Bailey
Thank You Ashton Bailey ah that son of
John Bailey oh look out probably nobody
get John in here make him super check
says I know I'm a minority look I know I
am a minority no all right not many
people are my race I would love it if we
actually said I know I'm a minority and
that was his reason like and are you
proud what I know I am Armenian and
we're not supposed to like the last year
my whole community has cast me out
because also I think Bubba we should
have made more at the box office
I agree with you on both yeah I percent
agree with you on both I love I love the
washer I loved it when I first saw
everybody eventually over time
bumblebee should have made more money at
the box office
I thought that was great and I have a
theory too that I think the big you look
the big YouTube movie critics talking
like Stockman Jeremy John's pick flick
pick Ethel flick pick in their angry Joe
actually yeah like the big critics I
don't remember what Chris Stockman and
Jeremy John said about bumblebee
but I remember angry joe really didn't
like bumblebee and I think like their
opinions factor and more than a Rotten
Tomatoes capsule I can see for a lot of
people yeah because a lot of people
don't trust buttons especially where
fandom comes from the fandom is will go
to those guys you know and I think there
because it's like when they don't like
something but the Rotten Tomatoes
consensus is fresh yeah I often notice
there's a weird correlation where the
box-office underperform oh we got Erica
sup Erica in the chat Tuesday cabin in
the woods is awesome Erica was at was
she at the Sanders rally which totally
paid off
listen disturbia
you guys were ships in the night
disturbia I I would much rather make a
well-paying masterpiece than a ship
Marvel movie no no I would make a [ __ ]
Marvel movie because that was skyrocket
my career and then you can make a
masterpiece nobody sees matte beer
saying use this to buy spaghetti meat
spaghetti since meat isn't needed oh
thank you Matt that's so kind and cuz
I'm now a pescetarian that I can't have
I can't have meat but I get these
vegetarian meatballs of the spaghetti
Olivia makes a spaghetti so good um
again there's great ways to make veg she
she knows how to cook up a damn
delicious vegetarian dish but like she
made something like a beef stew
yesterday I was like this this tastes
like real beet it's only been I'm like
I'm a little over a month I haven't had
meat so I can I still remember what meat
tastes like you know imagine the day you
forget I know
will I ever too long
Miami girl 2 3 4 thank you so much for
community the chat she says I hope you
guys are staying safe Thank You Miami
girl I hope you're staying safe in Miami
on those beaches with all your friends
partying it up spring bro it's a you
have to be safe out there this is Miami
like one of the most dangerous parts
because they're not really enforcing the
corner oh hey I think somebody sent me I
think a message on Instagram saying that
Florida was just going into lockdown yes
or something like a few days ago so I
guess they're they're joining the cause
my god I feel like Florida especially
like the Miami always strikes me as like
kind of like Vegas
but if Vegas didn't bother to go there
no we're all super families rules for
families I feel like it's just like all
adult okay so we got here Andrew cook
thanks for returning buddy and ec thank
you for contributing to the chat buddy
mm-hmm which film do you guys prefer the
Godfather 1 or part 2 or part 3 this is
a judgment-free zone ooh I grew up
thank you for thanking for shared the
chat I grew up thinking Godfather Part 2
I recently
part 1 and part 2 towards the end of
last year to Olivia and upon rewatching
I would say Godfather one now oh wow
yeah I just think I love the DeNiro
storyline but I feel like it takes a
little while to find the Pacino
storyline just as gripping hmm
and whereas Godfather one I think is
just really compelling from beginning to
end I think part two is shot better but
I think part one is the better story and
say I was I love both I really do I
really love both but I would I
inch it towards Godfather one I think
it's that thing where I would maybe
sooner watch part two just as like for
enjoyment but yeah but part one yeah I
think is the is the granddaddy still you
know yeah that's a fair point man yeah
it's a fair point but you know Godfather
3 hoo hoo I want a show of people who
love Godfather I just want to see who
actually does like because I've never
heard a good word against it have you
seen Godfather 3 only moments of
Godfather's who have never said it's
legacy and I want to know because
somebody out there must like it yeah of
course hey just say hey catch up on the
[ __ ] super trust me I know we're not
coming oh you should see we have the
list we don't have the chat view I'm
pretty sure there are people in the
super chat who are like I'm gonna turn
this off and come back tomorrow to see
what they that's right super yeah we're
gonna have to start time-stamping these
if you want to see your super response
come back tomorrow it makes it sound
like we're just sitting here going
talking about nothing really we just
take way too long to answer I mean no
we're getting sidetracked I make it too
much of a bit off of your super chair
yeah moving on ik Erik thank you so much
juice buddy flash that tattoo on screen
please do will patch you in John wick 3
disappear towards seeing John wick 3
disappointing efforts but then the bush
song at the end hype me up
watching it's good but not great and my
name is DJ oh wait oh he said to me in
and talking on Instagram his name he
says I thought I thought you were
telling me you're a DJ oh come play a
party friend live event can someone like
my name is Greg by the way with a number
or something rainy that somebody took
the time really or did you pick it
yourself oh really so much more sense
than me it's good that's good hey we
rank you good isn't good to know you DJ
thank you
I John wick 3 i actually liked more the
second time i watched it as i had a big
problem of the middle chunk of the
storytelling but i liked it a lot more
than i watched it i don't play pool yeah
oh dude we couldn't rip our eyes off how
do people do like this for our
Lightroom's I'm so hungry I know like
I'm still feeling good aw what's up
vicious no Erica Tuesday has been to
Bish's dogs Greggy veggie I made that
I'm starting to get that microwave mine
thing where you don't have a headache or
eyestrain but your your head just has
that general like reheated leftovers
feeling when you when you look at it
Erica Tuesdays on shrooms right now
lucky why don't you want you bring that
over here I'm gonna I don't mind turn it
into a trick I don't mind admitting this
because I've tried for like 10 years and
almost every human being I meet is like
dude I told I could you not it's really
been the one and it's come to the point
where I'm like obviously gonna keep
throwing out there because I know it's
never gonna happen you need it I'm like
Steve Kerr on the foreo virgin like
saying no no you need to keep throwing
it out there because eventually you'll
the one person is like oh yeah I've got
some on yeah we could drip drop some
right everyone always says I don't get
never ten years say but when that first
when that first experience comes along
its gonna blow your mind hey hey
someone's bringing up about damn leaving
screen junkies and I want to say like I
totally that's a but I'm a huge screen
junkies fan and I watch phantom
entertainment as well I think that I
think Dan is like exceptionally talented
and I feel like it would be a big loss
for screen junkies me he's like the
movie fights champion Rd with Dan he
seems to be like a fan favorite such
leader of the group
he's a senpai and III admire the [ __ ]
out of the guys and on top of that it's
like it only lends more credibility to
him the fact of how well of a Schmo down
chant the guy is but it's like what him
doing his own [ __ ] I'm like meh I I'm
excited to see what it what Dan will do
I really am I fully support it I don't
still support screen joggers I love
those guys I think they're a fantastic
channel fantastic channel mm-hmm I liked
his announcement more on the second
watch hey guys a recent brain you have
yoga I'm gonna watch Ozark so thanks a
bunch for that you guys are hilarious
Oh tony cornett that's so sweet of you
thank you dude I'm glad that video had
an impact I can't tell if you're on
drugs in that video or you're pissed off
in your your thumbnail pose right or if
you're not sure if that's the camera on
your front-facing phone but either way
I'm glad I appreciate it how do you like
Oz Arc I'm bringing this up because I
kid you not
my brother texted me today 252 p.m. have
you seen ozark not yet why like it all
nope you gotta watch it it's on par with
Breaking Bad in many ways I like it
better in a few areas yeah I've heard
that before it's damn good
alright the highest watch shows on
Netflix right
I think number two because that is the
one that clinched it for me I was like
it's it's the highest ranked well then
thank you to wait have we met Tony Tony
current did Court home did I suck your
dick it and Ally want stuff that's a
Rolodex right there I don't know you
have a type a Craigslist pass can really
be confusing look out kids
oh and Nissa Nissa how many other women
are up against a reject nation for John
oh don't answer that pretty much we have
an eighty five percent male demographic
yes percent of females got 14 percent of
the 15 percent demographic is your
competition that's what I'm here to tell
you right now now 1% i relish in the
attention and i go kiss away from me for
i am taken mm-hmm but i live streams
those like one person viewing a marathon
keep live-streaming and maybe we'll just
get more and more more people the more
and more and more we go will stay on the
youtube front page for a long time is
there the longest lives room we've done
so far
Oh hands down Thank You Aneesa we got to
catch up on some other questions here
I'm getting very you wanna cliff bar I
got snacks bruh for today for every day
we work chill level TV react amore
BuzzFeed insolvent some Smosh well thank
you for the super chat too but bus we
don't solve this actually blocked a
couple of our videos someone say the
chance with those guys really fun it's
like some of the company like there's
some of these automatic claims and
there's this interesting thing with
reactions that often happens with us is
a lot of the times some companies will
get back specifically with like an
actual feedback some just let us let
them go specifically like how it should
have ended whoa copyright claim us but
then let it go like almost every single
time and I don't know if I was like you
know what we like these guys because
we've had
happened before where people have
claimed to us and they've caught him
back to us saying you know we actually
saw your video and we really like you
guys so and and a big a big thing too
that we constantly get feedback on from
other companies is the one when they let
claims go is we like that you actually
gave a full commentary afterwards I'm
not just saying that to toot our own
horn I'm saying that B that's a big part
of what has led to claims go it's what
we really like that you guys actually
give full commentary afterwards and
thank you for the work well and that
plays into fair use which is a dubious
hill to climb especially on YouTube and
so yeah the commentary here you know
it's not the biggest draw the channel it
does serve a purpose because then you
can point at it and go look I didn't
just redisplay your video and add almost
nothing and the thing with BuzzFeed
unsolved is like companies like BuzzFeed
are a big chain of command like that
like the people who make the videos prob
are not the people who are running the
claims department I'm mostly when you
know so it's different when it's a
smaller group and they can see the
videos you're making like new rock stars
will react to their videos and half of
them get includes copyrighted content so
they're not monetized most of the times
like the videos views i rack up on a new
rock stars video those are monetized
views but then eventually they'll let
the let the claim go and I know they
like us they've invited us on their
channel they're shattered and the
Theory's gone remote now so yeah I'm
gonna hit them back up like if you guys
are gonna remote let's try make it work
but um with new rock stars even the
video where we were shouted out were
were featured on screen and we're in the
thumbnail of Erik Bosse pointing to us
yeah they're automatic claims Department
claimed that video do you monetize for a
couple days and then eventually was let
go and so Erik let us go personally my
whole point where this is BuzzFeed and
Smosh have not gone to the same thing
and when you get a couple of blocks or
like that we shouldn't touch anymore
just to be safe
yeah so that's why Niraj darshan think
you do Dark City did it thank you so
much for contributing to the chat d Dark
City didn't enjoy a first love denarii
why
one of our best friends Andrew Gordon
introduced in the dark city underrated
film got kinda masted around the time
because like the matrix and stuff yeah
did it the matrix reuse sets from dark
city for that film you might be right
that sounds kind of familiar to me I'm
not entirely sure but yeah dark city was
a movie that I at least enjoyed a lot
more the second time I don't I didn't
dislike it but yeah yeah second time
watching it that is a yeah go back and
revisit it cuz that's an
underappreciated movie from that time
there's a lot of stuff that borrows from
it yeah even Holgate saying to us right
now where do we all go by the way what
are we all gonna eat someone's asking I
don't know yet I'm gonna get pizza with
my girlfriend yeah she is addicted right
now it's a Final Fantasy 7 oh yes I
start playing a Breanna white strange
rebel gaming woo I started doing a lot
of YouTube here right here on the real
rejects is the one is the one of the
main characters in that game so guys go
play it Oh God
Ethan Holgate saying to us did you guys
watch six underground Michael Bay magic
haven't seen it yet me appreciate the
super Channel I'm always bummed when we
get a super chat like that and my answer
is like no off the wall but just like
Michael Bay just got to go to town I
probably want I probably will watch it
one day though when things are a little
chiller
hey Jack Pole thank you that's a really
kind thing to say about us thank you
very much appreciated Jesse pop you're
so sweet here you're the funny one
Robert Baqarah thank you didn't like a
bug's life / love snakes on a plane
well done that's a great hot take I want
to know now I this is a great double
feature right there but I also just want
to know what the ratio is of people who
share his opinions who dislikes a bug's
life and how many people love snakes on
a plane in which group is bigger um I I
don't think snakes on a plane is as fun
as people you know what there was too
much if there was too much you know
snakes on a plane didn't have it it
didn't have the chance to live as a
genuine bad movie before getting a cult
following mister because there was
already a cult movie before it ever
[ __ ] came out and it had like all
this hype and then they went back and
reshot stuff for ya as of the hype and
and I think that's weirdly a thing that
worked against it yeah yeah
because I saw III went an opening night
and there were people there who had like
snake toys and [ __ ] like people are
rowdy it was a psyched up crowd when I
went with my dad people already embrace
the cult of it but I'm like but it's
normally a movie like that needs to be
bad first yeah yeah yeah it's a chance
to have that like shame before it gets
the cult following yeah it makes me
wonder like if it if you found it now
and you weren't aware of its marketing
and them and the cultural thing at the
time and you just saw it as a random
movie on TV would it play as well
because there's also something I think
that movie breached we're making and
intentionally so bad it's good movie is
a conundrum in and of itself you know
and I think that movie kind of helped
breach that conversation because there
are a lot of movies especially since
that in grindhouse that have come out
trying to be intentionally bad and it's
tricky to do that and actually make it
fully enjoyable oh man we got huh oh
it's interesting comment here from
Charles Taylor I'm here in the chat
regular chat here I'm not a woman but I
am gay and we'll fight you for him for
you I don't know what that meant
I mean you know and then disturbia is
saying Woody Allen or Mel Gibson Mel
Gibson thousand percent
I guess Mel Gibson oh absolutely yeah
Wow let's open this box
we got Vincent Lamaze saying I was
bullied for having a big forehead just
wondering if you all experienced the
same thing I've gotten criticized we can
relate though it's gonna meet him you've
got made fun of it Jesus man
maybe once or twice Micke frizzy
mcfreely
you have a delicious name the dark night
gets worse work Dark Knight Rises gets
better I don't know if I can agree with
you on that thank you for the super chat
by the way but I don't know if I could
agree with you on that I feel like it's
actually opposite yeah like we saw the
Dark Knight in the theaters like a year
ago and it was still [ __ ] amazing
where's Dark Knight Rises I'll just
think about it sometimes be like that
has got him not as good there is great
stuff still in there but there are
things that stand out that are like ah
that wasn't a great moment or I didn't
like the way they did this necessarily
so it's it's not the blemishes haven't
been rival - right yeah surpass TDK I
get you all right guys here we go here
we go hey he grabs his Greg smokes pot
what who I have never what never proven
gone down the street to the shop right
on the corner which I call the Costco of
weed shops yeah with the secret door I
have never gone there twice and one yeah
I don't know team I've never I'm with
this guy a lot and I can I can verify he
doesn't I want but I will clarify this a
lot of the times people think I'm high
when I'm really not but like we usually
have our our schedules anywhere usually
from 9 a.m. till 6 p.m. on average and
I'm not high during that time not a lot
of time it's like do I occasionally yeah
I do but I don't I'm not I'm not a heavy
posner please I'm really not a heavy
smoker I used to be that I used to be I
am NOT
I was a heavy cigarette and paws burger
but I definitely I don't so executives
anymore but I don't not heavy pot smoker
but I do smoke fools and I have been
trying to try shrooms for 10 years you
are
Lynnae hey you're back thank you my dear
for contributing to the chat I will be
in LA for Wrestlemania 37 I hate it dusk
till dawn after watch re watch it after
I liked it so wait after re-watching it
after you liked it you disliked it or
you disliked it and I just liked it in
Washington liked it alright pick up on
the chat dude she's getting at I'm sorry
Lynnae when you're in LA you let us know
mm-hmm you definitely let us know and
that's Ben fact Olivia my want to go to
Wrestlemania 37 dude I think she would
love that
Olivia ooh somebody do we watch the WWE
match John Cena vs. the flying we tried
to but we couldn't see it John Cena
jokes you want to go to Wrestlemania 37
this is really happening this is a plan
right now you guys are watching history
in the making
I mean I'll buy the tickets he said down
the street classic Japanese cinema yes I
see some Kurosawa I've probably seen
some other filmmakers who I can't name
very well but yeah I've seen some
Kurosawa joints for sure just Tetsuo
count is that classic Japanese oh yeah
get us an animal bring us an animal hmm
oh thank you so much Quentin everything
I watched these two my anxiety goes away
oh thank you so much I'm glad that to
hear that we want to reduce as much
anxiety let's meet up at WrestleMania 37
you know what dead meat James might be
there too huge wrestling fan again all I
tell you guys a true story I was doing
alright I'm checking out um because we
can't take any it's gonna he's gonna run
right the [ __ ] out about this not
interested
and not an on camera strictly behind so
it's okay whoever wants to come in and
out come in and out even though I know
you don't want the door open because
we're being too loud and we're
distracting bring me copper than we're
distracting her from her Final Fantasy
game play yes so deadly James who's a
very successful youtuber he invited he
vided us to his wrestling watch party
for Wrestlemania right WrestleMania
Royal Rumble the other side I'm just
gonna burst of that door like the
kool-aid and then what was the one we
missed it was like do we miss a rage in
the cage for some I don't know
so it was Royal Rumble and then we go to
this party and most people don't know
there's a lot of people there but most
people don't really know wrestling who
are there Olivia major wrestling fan not
pledged for a patron but she is pledged
by the name because that's how cats like
to be picked up on yeah so we go there
all these people are there next thing
you know for majority of the party it's
dead meat James and Olivia talking yeah
you're you sure too late you saw like
yeah damn going back and forth those are
the only two who really know wrestling
everybody else is like we're having a
good time they're friends and everyone
very true dude disturbia is coming up
with all kinds of crazy ask questions
where are we at in the soup okay the
only one I see you back here dude
hello-o
where we at okay Rowe Harris I'm losing
my mind
rogue one thank you so much Darius
Harris for contribute to the chat that's
all I said
no thank you rogue one I liked it
until I rewatched it didn't like up when
I first saw it but saw it as an adult
appreciate a lot more it's interesting
that we're getting a lot of kids movies
that that people didn't like his kid
like these are kids movies mmm
like it as kids hmm and then they grew
up liked it
yeah which is kind of ironic but those
are kids boy and if ever there was an
argument for the fact that animation as
a medium is a much broader thing than
just for children that is one of those
things because yeah the like movies like
Pixar yeah there's tons of stuff that's
fun and enjoyable for kids but
especially one leg up has a lot of drama
in it yeah it's true
that's very true a lot of thoughtful
storytelling hated Space Jam as a kid
grew up loved master he's got all the
context a commentary on the industry I
really picked up on the sense of Michael
Jordan and being a man who's detached
who feels like a failure due to his
baseball efforts not going well and
really that's why he has an emotionless
performance it was intentional it was
not bad acting and that's why he doesn't
care at all about his family during the
movie is because he they don't even
bring him any fulfillment exactly
Darius Harris rogue one
you see I loved it the first time I saw
it and the first time I saw I was the
only time I watched it and a lot of
people just talked so much sharing it
that it kind of ruined the experience of
going back to watch it for me so I
haven't seen it again just because the
thing with some of these giant [ __ ]
movies especially being on YouTube is
you get a lot of opinions in your head
and after a while you're like that's why
I distance myself in spooby I want to
watch it because I think about her all
the [ __ ] static so I do want to
re-watch it though and I'm always
tempted to be when I especially when I
come across the Star Wars section on the
Disney Plus app [ __ ] like I've been
watching so much Simpsons at the time of
this damn Excel and you're welcome
America that was actually that animation
remark was based on conversation that we
had with Erica so Anissa livid is
telling us
thank you for again for this extra super
champion did she did she that she didn't
get a notification post about us but I
don't think our live streams ever really
notify anyone do you guys gonna notify
first I get so many on my home screen I
feel like we should yeah you know
especially because we scheduled them
typically
in advance sadly through our programming
I'm sorry to hear that
most people don't hit the notification
bell for us I'll find your video yes
wait now venom 2 trailer isn't coming
tomorrow is it we should get off this
chat some more
is the venom 2 trailer coming tomorrow
I'm saying so people say it in the
sights I'm cool that would be cool what
time please don't be 6 a.m. please don't
be 6 a.m. that's all I asked that it's
not 6 a.m. if the venom 2 trailer is
coming tomorrow for God's sake please
it's Saturday who's gonna be up at 6 to
watch a trailer on Saturday we don't
know if it is also TM gets notifications
yeah everybody sound off who's got
notification to no no no no where's
trailer go back don't trust ok so what
do we got here oh we caught up where
every time we think we've caught up we
have Edgar Wright show directed at man I
totally agree with you yeah I didn't
think Peyton Reed did a bad job but
everything ant-man needs is a movie I
could write as great John yes just
please read my cell another movie to
them that you didn't like until rewatch
or you did like until rewatch yeah come
on John see here in my brain which movie
that comes directly to mind oh wow
Brendan V that is so sweetie Brendan B
has said to us hey you handsome guys
long time no see just wanted to thank
you for being a source of positivity in
these trying times love you guys Thank
You Brendan V now when you say handsome
guys who do you personally find more
attractive who do you find more
attractive seriously mmm
I mean it's not a competition
it poorly [ __ ] Oh fine fine
I tried to be polite because I don't
know if you're just being like sweet by
saying that but the thing is most people
most women find John to be more
attractive mm-hmm and normally when my
hair is like all curled out gay guys
find me more attractive John so I just
want to know and I'm not gonna read the
regular chat because I don't want to see
all the woman chiming in about John
being the more attractive I'll keep an
eye don't is that John is so attractive
or something he'll point it now I'm
talking like not during a live screen
who'd be like I gotta tell Craig yeah
I'm gonna stockpile them for the
remainder of this year so that through
2021 I can just start dropping them all
the time
cédric pallet ei where is your source
send us your source all right little do
we know it's John creating multiple fake
accounts just to try to make me feel
better I'm not good of a friend all
right guarantee it but I also make the
account okay I know hundred percent
which is sadder what do we got here oh
we're almost almost there we're almost
there
then Little Caesars five dollar pizza
you got a chance anis again or we go now
oh my god good Tuesday Erica Oh Thank
You Erica John's writing you up a very
special patron in the day shop yeah I'm
gonna spend too long on it you spent too
long and be like Johnny you don't need
to spend that's like I have to Greg
that's just the amount of pressure I
like to praise economize just saying hey
to my bras PS if you don't want art for
our our hip real rejects send me a while
be like the [ __ ] are patreon
I think offers sticker packs now we
should talk Erica yes absolutely let's
talk in our hot tub
I mean wait you're the one with the hot
test let's talk wait we got a hot tub
here can't be used because of the court
well you know just just fight everybody
to the death for the brights to use it
although I mean in a Jacuzzi it's so hot
you'd be burning germs around I found
out is that mortgage mortgage owners mmm
don't have to pay don't have to pay
whatever the bank yeah so but we still
have to pay rent here that's ridiculous
see that's the thing he doesn't the
owner of this place doesn't have to pay
anything but wow I I'm not gonna get
into a huge diatribe but personally I
think that's pretty despicable if you're
it is very not to pass the savings along
to the friggin people who rely on you
for a home but Erica yeah let's talk
about it let's talk let's talk
yes let's turn this relationship from
friendship into this nice ship I feel
like people I think especially if we're
ever on a Skype call or something with
someone who wants to do a brand deal
with us are always a little bit
surprised by how not serious we are like
we take the the deed like that the
negotiating and the talking points
seriously obviously but the amount of
like sarcastic quips I make I think
they're they always seem at first like a
little thrown off by like oh they're not
that serious which set atomic we got
we're in the process of hashing out this
brand deal with this company that's
different unique and we're we are very
excited about it like the I'm tempted to
just kind of show you guys this [ __ ]
they've sent over because it's some very
cool stuff and but yeah we got on the
phone with this guy he lives in
Australia his name is Russell and like
it ended up turning into a 45-minute
Skype call where we weren't even talking
about the products really literally 45
minutes guys call
chatting yeah and I'm excited to show
you guys a prop but Thank You Erica
Tuesday yeah the same please talk Oh
Anissa has confirmed how to say her name
my name is free pass uh nice uh nasty
wrong Greg it's okay I still love you
and yes totally ready to hang out oh my
god anis you're coming on a little
strong don't you think she wants to hang
but I know what this is is exactly like
every other every other woman they've
always been like getting close to me to
get close to this one to get close trust
me it's happened many times in real life
and it's happening right now I know
you're tricking ISA don't think I didn't
notice you said I'm attractive in the
chat yeah I know what the [ __ ] you're up
to Aneesa hmm but I thank you so much
for the support it's been over a year
now
okay you know what yes yes I will send
you guys I will sing now I'll send you
upset everyone and everyone everyone get
an address come visit and be taken
immediately office we can't open up a Bo
box right absolutely yeah yeah don't you
thank you Aneesa you're so sweet it has
been over a year
Azim the dream review is that a YouTube
channel my friend let's look him up leg
up is um hold on John
if you don't want to I love your
thumbnail deep hey thank you for the
super chat hey guys how do you all
manage to make a reaction video is about
getting copper I just started the second
up on my react for you it got blocked oh
well we have special connections and we
are paid in advance for every rock half
of the videos in the week our team on it
so there you go it's just something you
got to do you know what I mean and we
talked earlier about how a lot of the
companies like will eventually let the
claims go but I mean it's just something
you kind of once why I got a deal
it's a crapshoot a lot of the time I
don't want say an Aussie you know in all
fairness there was a point were was like
half of the videos it wouldn't say half
now I would say like maybe a third of
the videos throughout the week get it
slowly the the D monetization z' and the
yellow dollar bills have at least kinda
chill they've shown that low me but you
mean yesterday's video so yeah I mean
but for I would say at least a third of
the videos I have two thirds of the
video and you know it to redirect focus
making more positive two-thirds of ESO
not been modest but honestly there's not
much you can really do to work around it
if you're covering like a show or a
music video I suggest you cut it up yeah
obviously for the reaction purposes
I had a cut up version of a joiner Lucas
one but it didn't get blocked so I was
like alright I'm just good for the river
or the full length one and if it doesn't
as I have a cut-off one ready to reload
in case that gets blocked but it wasn't
blocked I don't really have as long as
we've been doing this we don't really
have advice for you because if it's
music video react or if it's a song it's
probably going to get blocked or be
monetized like that's the problem with
trailers especially Netflix movies and
Netflix shows it's like they usually
have a song and there are some popular
song that [ __ ] six goddamn seconds I
like with the Joker second trailer oh
yeah six seconds got the video to
monetize they they they get really anal
in some ways about that and again it
goes back to the fair use I'm like six
seconds is not twenty seconds yeah and
it was annoying because I mean we we
really like we put together opening
sketch for that that took time to put
together not a huge chunk of time but it
took time in it yeah and then and I
thought it would be the song we use in
the sketch that got the video monetize
but it wasn't it was [ __ ] six seconds
of the trailer like really one for that
stuff it it drives me up a wall cuz I'm
like this is promotional material this
is this is literally for an advertiser
and we hit yeah which is great and we
what we mainly learned about was yeah we
hit like a number fourteen trending
which was a [ __ ] great feeling
um but yeah I mean there's a bummer like
and I'm not gonna see any of 0% yeah
sometimes you get shared revenue you can
you can make a little look I'll gladly a
acknowledge that there are channels out
there who definitely like especially the
channels that do like videos once a week
that put way more work into their videos
that we do generally generally speaking
our work is not as difficult to edit or
chop up but we still spend time per vide
we do we like see and oming yeah like
the the video we put up to date took at
least two and a half hours to fully
complete and so we still do put time
into the videos yeah that's like the
minimum time talking about it yeah so
yeah they can be it can be frustrating
when everyone but everyone but one of
the cool things that he kind of hope
they're like well maybe the wreck of an
audience enough with the videos that are
monetized that aren't monetized you know
the watch the monetized videos but
that's just you know I'm not trying to
make this into a rat's butt I'm just
trying to say I'm sorry we don't like we
deal with it so I get your pain
Ashton Bailey thank you but thank you
for that
super check Ashton Bailey's thank you so
much again buddy
my middle name is John names buddies lol
also you should make toilet paper with
the real rejects logo on it are you
saying we're [ __ ] thanks are you saying
thanks you piss on us
Ashton John Bailey someone is this how
it works you know that the toilet paper
a peon it you know I'm going through so
much of it I can't help it hmm I would
love to market real rejects toilet paper
I would actually love some real ray we
could help for a world that she was rub
it in my face oh oh we got this great
comet mmm you see that's some people no
real like all the reading are super
telling like a true
we got this great comment I'm going to
read it out loud right now from Gabriel
90m not super Chad literalmente solo
escribo tantaros por que realmente
quiero que Johnny Greg pero sobre todo
Greg no notification is coming Terrace
gracias Tico
sonic huevos thank you it is 9 inches I
don't know how you knew that but it is 9
inches yes really is and I got three
three of them it is incredible and she
and chicas do love it
I'm just got to cringe psych it actually
just for you guys to actually kind of
read what you said and thank you what
was it uh I'm not gonna translate it cuz
I'll probably make a fool out of myself
but you know there was like a letter Joe
Biden there's you know like you know
like thank you boys I'll have to go I'll
have to go look at the rest have you
guys watched the show Banshee no oh I
remember when that was coming out in the
post cool it was on stars but ganja
sorrows oh my god I love your name so as
I go to a shop every few weeks it's it's
it's on the corner and I Crash Bandicoot
that [ __ ] up just go in there start
spinning and [ __ ] up the whole dispenser
Parappa the rapper hijack okay
oh thanks nemesis you have a good time
going to sleep mmm no you can't leave
copper your eye candy for the background
no can people see what you're doing
alright how would you all rank the
Jurassic Park franchise plus the short
from battle a bigger rock oh thank you
for the question that's a fun one
I like the other ones guys step it up I
would say mmm I would say Jurassic Park
one yes at the top I would say Jurassic
Park - yes I would say Jurassic world I
would say Jurassic Park that's a
Jurassic world
Jerr ass bad Olympic Rock Jurassic Park
3 Jurassic world fallen Kingdom really
don't like fallen Kingdom like a lot
really didn't like that movie hmm
literally only one I'm like I kind of
yeah and uh goodness I mean I kind of
feel that way about Jurassic world in
hindsight just thinking about it now I
guess I would go drastic park drastic
part two three or fallen Kingdom to
depending and then Jurassic world yeah
that's good did not did not does
Jurassic world like really that was a
movie I had a lot of fun the first time
and I had relatively good will towards
it and then i-i've since then and since
seeing it again thanks for the question
dude Sebastian ever as a pet up his two
girls one cup for you guys okay yeah I
get that
oh and the pain'll yeah I saw the second
I didn't like two girls one cup the
first time I saw but I upon a free watch
I understood the deeper context however
Payne Olympics way better the first time
alright way better it really pales in
comparison Aaron Paul a chill level TV
thank you dude Thank You Aaron Paul is
Wolverine rewatched wrong like more like
more Aaron Paul's Wolverine I think
would actually be a decent fit I don't
think he'd be my top pick but I think
he'd be a good fit yeah if he could
transform that's the only thing I would
need is is for him to be lost and he do
a different voice miss professor actual
yeah yeah he does have a very Aaron Paul
thing about him except I mean even when
he's Todd but maybe least so he's Todd
Oh Lauren Martinez happy birthday to you
tomorrow
happy birthday to you happy birthday
[Music]
happy birthday to you and many extra and
thanks for super chatting us on your
birthday nice I think we made it to the
last one
when y'all have a million will you throw
a party yes six years um around here we
had a million we would certainly would
yes
throwing a party if we gain a hundred
thousand subscribers every year or the
next three years we will be at a million
subscribers so yes in three years we
will hit we will throw yeah well throw a
party
we'll hit hunt anyone and everyone is
invited by that math we will hit a
million before we finish supernatural
that's when we should quit the channel
the day we hit a million the day we hit
a million go on livestream op the mics
and it's over that scream go thank you
for the super chat thank you for the
super chat Anissa but yeah and guess
what you're invited to there too
ooh how would you rank John wick one
three two yeah thank you and yes and
this year invited all you're invited to
tour million parts so invited to the
Millie P okay now we've really reached
the last question and then we'll take
one regular question dragon soldier
thank you so much dragon soldier do you
two have a [ __ ] root boot that you
think out does the original or at least
sounds great in its own and what reboot
do you absolutely hate a a horror reboot
that we think out does the original I
would say now this isn't fair cuz I
never finished the original but I would
say the remake of maniac which John one
Vin's me to watch it's a heavy movie
John you're welcome
thank you John that's for you
[Music]
do you have one I got a few I mean are
better The Crazies improves upon the
original yeah and that's a good solid
standalone as well you know that's a
really solid film I would say um I mean
I think you could theoretically make an
argument that the remake of Evil Dead
arguably outdoes the original Evil Dead
I wouldn't swap them for each other
because I wouldn't watch them but for
the same reason I would not say that I
think there's an argument to be made
John look
opinions are sometimes subjective
sometimes when I disagree its objective
realize that my mistake Jacobi uh and
what reboot do we actually hate ooh
there's gotta be there's definitely a
reboot that we've seen together that we
hate oh oh let's hear it
Nightmare on Elm Street is a pretty
awful one that is that brought my day
down after I watched it actually yes I
walked around moving all throughout his
neighborhood listening to MadWorld by
Gary Jules
every time I'm just seeing there's like
montage moments of like good Freddie
kills oh thank you dragon slider so
sweet of you
yeah Cedric pallets here's been here
since 2014 he has now left the live
stream yeah I've been waiting in the
room a lot
Gabriel nine teams asking Titanic Roma
stars born at cars three Oh easily stars
born powder I could even rank this [ __ ]
for you a stars born Titanic cars three
and also up at Rome at the bottom no no
no I switch cars through a fighting word
however when I fought damn Earl in a
fight of Roma versus stars born I had to
learn to hate Roma to win that are
grained in my brain I did a little too
good job all right we will do anything
for Eddie thank you which modern musical
do you think thank you deserves a fill
meditation other than Hamlet's that mine
is probably Hades town Oh a Hades town
movie would be very cool it's just
having I haven't seen the show it's a
it's a it's taking the world it's like
the next kind of like big musical
everyone's talking about there's any
Schmo down fans here I want you guys to
let Clark Woolf now I'm specifically
mentioning this this one and and are
your your friend Mary Mary O'Neill Mary
O'Neill's in this hmm
we I did you go to that show huh yeah we
took time out to go watch Clark Wolff
was in this show and Mero Neal and then
my friend Alyssa we wanted and that's
why we watched it that's why we [ __ ]
watch it was a listen and listen or
what's that that's right of course you a
who's your idea what was it called
slasher slashed slashed there's this
musical they put up called slash the
musical and I and I've seen a lot of my
lot of people's plays where I've had to
be like great loved I had tears in my
eyes this was a funny
Harris [ __ ] play and it got picked up
for a longer run it was a great play
Clark wolf from the Schmo down and it
Commissioner over there Commissioner
Gordon it Commission's Commissioner
Gordon the new Batgirl movie because
they've gone all woke that that is a I I
think you can get this song somewhere
uh yeah yeah the display itself was
absolutely hysterical and I really hope
that they or they get an opportunity to
uh to bat into something bigger it's
like a spoof on a t slasher films but it
wasn't generic at all and it was really
clever and I'm telling you you know what
[ __ ] awful place this was genuinely
great so you wrote a fade you'd be like
hey Greg mention this play / / / / /
you're fast tense gotcha I
but the Hades town is probably like the
best answer right now but personally I
think just for me it would be cool to
see I don't know what I'm talking about
way I think it'd be cool to see them
take one of the movies have been made
into a musical and like film the musical
because there's like an evil dead
musical and there's a reanimate or
musical that both you know like Evil
Dead runs in Vegas you know like people
put it on periodically but it runs
consistently in Vegas and reanimate or
the musical had a huge like cult
following still does and so like to see
those movies retransfer but I think
could be kind of cool but you know
that's just amusing the officer friends
who are the only one asked I would say
friends in a million years there's
something there's some episodes
I was actually than you're kind of
boring but I / I love the office I
really do
oh yeah took me a while to get on that
train and and thanks to you I did I got
you on the office train mm-hmm what
about the what's a sex train word sex
train yeah sex works like a bunch of
guys like buggers actually called
comment below so that YouTube will like
hide your comment and we need to approve
it which oh don't snow blue waffles in
here Sebastian Aneesa you should go to
bed it's 9:15 in Texas when you all
first met did you know you're gonna be
friends forever hmm also now actually I
thought we'd be enemies for life who
until they save me from a from a burning
building which was on the edge of a
cliff yeah we have one of those moments
yeah we're looking in my eyes I was
pulling him in and it was like I hate
you and I respect you seriously be safe
at the hospital please say thank you I
because we need you at the hospital like
though Olivia wants to go outside and
hang out but Peter wants to go out and
just touch people's faces no we have a
patron it's a great friend actually
Natalie thorn
she works at a hospice care in Ireland
I'm always concerned for the people who
are like working directly in hospitals
yeah so please be extra safe but no we
did not know we'd be friends forever as
a matter of fact we've been gone we went
to school together since first grade and
we didn't become friends till third
grade two whole years was until we found
Pokemon do you realize we were both like
that's rare when I third grey you
discover hey we both love Nick
oh yeah uh we I was loving dick in
eighth grade level not not a night game
no we just like looking at dicks so
they're fascinating evolution were like
I mean yours is lot wider dude oh wow
how strange
you're a weird red Craig I was like I
know what hang out yeah John's danced
out over Jake suit weirdly brought us
closer together
yes very straining order did not work if
anything it just encouraged your parents
did not get along with my parents
there's a story about Oh as seeing the
dreamer bi Greg I like JW more than
what's JW Jurassic world more than the
loss loss loss world I did at first but
I rewatched the there was a point yeah
see the thing is when opinions change
when you put out reviews you get to get
comments like this um I did at first but
I would say Jurassic world is still more
entertaining but I think the loss
world's a better put together film also
a lot of people say baalbek rock was
better than both JW films y'all react
about I know I watched on my own time it
got blocked
I tend sometimes we do a test it where
uh there's this thing that we'll do
we'll take footage from an older that's
why we were we were headphones so
sometimes these tests without watching
the actual video so what we'll do is
we'll like we'll take footage of a
different reaction and then we'll drop
the video into iMovie on that reaction
but we're doing this all about like
watching the footage we set the audio to
the level we'll put it at we'll export
it on a very low resolution quality just
to quickly upload it to YouTube to see
if it'll get blocked
I guess we're like okay with cuz like we
might shoot the whole damn thing edit
the whole [ __ ] thing so in three
hours putting together and then it's oh
it's blocked for nothing yeah absolutely
not because it was a short film
distributed by Universal I was like it's
probably gonna get
so that's what I did for that one
without watching it and then sure enough
it was blocks and I just watched on my
own time that was really good it's
better it was definitely better than
another one but thank you azim the dream
reviews I think the last the lost world
has a bit more human heart in it sweet
dreams yeah I think lost world has more
heart and soul a little bit
thank you an ISA for being such a great
contribute one thing I know about John
is he's known he John's he knows his
musicals not as well as you think uh
some guys a poser he pretends to know
more than actually does see I'm that I
don't know what capilla real music I'm
the outlier is the strange one who's
like I haven't seen every musical and I
don't get to see like the newest ones
right when they open but I do like them
and I love to see a good one
Tiffany Hoffman year our closer tonight
yes marry kill Texas Chainsaw Massacre
virgil night of the dead and monster a
squad I would kiss the original night of
the Dead oh man I would marry monster
squad and I'd killed the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre that's probably the right way
to do it honestly has you know you
married a monster squad you're gonna get
least get some endearing wallet rain
going I was talking about
hey yeah with with you know the gill man
and the wolf man's got nerds then they
have confirmed so yeah so yeah I guess I
would kiss night a Living Dead Mary
monster squad and kill chainsaw but um
you know if I had to mix it up to not do
exactly as you I would just switch the
kiss in the mary ii mean i the Living
Dead sure I adore the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre well guys I am very hungry I'm
gonna go to bed I sincerely though wants
his okay here we go
do you guys have any bandanas and if so
you'll like them like bandit masks so
request when do you want to happen right
now I don't know if we have a bandana
don't have any bad Dada's I'm sorry tell
you what the next live stream we do is
ready to go and we'll rock them for you
hella bandana Thank You Brendan V Thank
You Brendan you look like a nice guy you
seem like a very nice guy you call this
handsome you specifically said Greg is a
lot hotter than John and I will always
remember that so thank you Thank You
Brendan B you will get a dick pic on
Instagram and because you're a guy you
won't cancel me so thank you that's how
it works
every guys just like respect Thank You
Brendan
yeah man series all right guys well I
want to thank everyone who if anyone
holy [ __ ]
thank you and also well done I hope that
everyone can be safe out there be wise
this livestream has been a total blast
there's a longest one we've ever done
they just get in Funari I'm so glad
Final Fantasy is able to keep my
girlfriend entertained and meter now we
will corrupt in one yeah I love everyone
who's been here lb start sounding off in
the chats guys off in the chat much love
hate seeing Jack pull Jorge the only one
Knicks Erica Tuesday clustered we have
and they're just looking everyone here
and then if there's anyone we miss brill
we will make it up to you I promise
much love to everyone have a good night
keep a lookout for a trailers revisited
of Suicide Squad tomorrow V gotcha man
just go back and watch the stream trust
me it was fun it was fun all right
much love seriously no no wait seriously
thank you
you guys the yes I made these livestream
is incredibly [ __ ] you have fun and
rewarding and honestly like we do
throughout the week we're shooting and
editing and all that fun jazz and
patrons a total [ __ ] blast as well
but it's fun to just let loose and then
be dumbasses for three hours yeah I'm
just a thank you thank you and you guys
you guys make a rewarding
thank you mm-hmm and yeah just to be
able to loosen up and to not have to you
know think is that of as many parts you
know it's like with these live streams
once you go you're on and it's really
fun to interface with you also thank you
so much yeah joining us especially like
when we're editing in the discussions a
lot of times I'm like we talked for 20
minutes let's get three hours worth
thank you to everyone who contributed to
the super chat stew and by the way we've
been taking percentages out of the super
chests to donate to charity I haven't
mentioned that to you because what we're
plenty I haven't talked about this job
but I'm planning on doing one of those
nights where we'll do a live stream yeah
all going to charity lesson yeah thank
you guys so much
wash your hands be safe much love much
seriously love you guys thank you much
love
be well